that's disgusting
the church of what's happening now is
brought to you by when on it
for all your supplement needs listen i
wouldn't be alive if it wasn't on it
between the shroom tech
and the hemp was protein i live off that
[ __ ] go to honey.com right now and press
in church boom
get 10 off off your order and don't
forget alpha brain you got 100 money
back guarantee and they don't even want
the product back number two ever since
we started this podcast every week some
[ __ ] body calls me and tortures me
about who's gonna win this weekend is it
the cowboys is it the cowboys came
through cowboys is it the patriots it's
always some story well let me tell you
this where your betting is is just as
important on who you're betting on so
that's why i always tell people to go
with mybookie.ag
join now today and my bookie will match
your deposit
up to 100 bonus
of your first deposit up to a thousand
dollars
that means you deposit they double it
and there you go use promo code church
c-h-u-r-c-h
to activate the offer here's the lock
visit my book e-a-g today and use promo
code church today you play you win you
get paid if you get a home underdog by
more than seven points seven and a half
or more at home
that's the luck you'll win four out of
five times on that that's what they
totally home underdogs
that's disgusting
the church of what's happening now is
brought to you by
on it
for all your supplement needs listen i
wouldn't be alive if it wasn't for
hunted between the shroom tech
and the hemp horse protein i live off
that [ __ ] go to audit.com right now and
press in charge boom
get 10 off off your order and don't
forget alpha brain you got 100
money-back guarantee
and they don't even want the product
back number two ever since we started
this podcast every week some [ __ ]
body calls me and tortures me about
who's gonna win this weekend is it the
cowboys is it the cowboys came through
cowboys is it the patriots it's always
some story well let me tell you this
where your betting is is just as
important on who you bet not so that's
why i always tell people to go with
mybookie.ag
join now today and my bookie will match
your deposit
up to a hundred percent bonus
of your first deposit up to a thousand
dollars
that means your deposit they double it
and there you go
use promo code church c-h-u-r-c-h
to activate the offer here's the lock
visit my book e-a-g today and use promo
code church today you play you win you
get paid if you get a home underdog by
more than seven points seven and a half
or more at home
that's the luck you'll win four out of
five times on that that's what they
totally home underdog
[ __ ] home underdog
oh [ __ ]
it's wednesday [ __ ]
the 13th
of september play the guitars i remember
this video crank this [ __ ] up dog
oh they were so hot oh [ __ ] it's joey
diaz with the two wise men the other one
got shot
dude this guy's so cool
you can't leave oh
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
is all you need
oh [ __ ] here we go [ __ ] cool
goalie here's
a little wiggle
[ __ ] 20 to life no parole the
church of what's happening now with two
of my favorite people in the world
mr hari shafir and mr lee syetz i
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
sleep away camp when that song came out
jerking off finding quiet moments when
everyone else is out of archery to
[ __ ] whip me out of jerk off yeah one
of those 75 74 74 she was 11. maybe what
year was it 85 86 yeah 11. okay yeah and
then just [ __ ]
so filthy little [ __ ] and summer
camp
coming on people's heads and shoes it
was hot and a lot of kids didn't know
what you were doing at 11. i wasn't
whacking off at that age scratching it
but people were talking about sex and
[ __ ] i don't know what the [ __ ] you made
you tried to make believe like you know
what they were saying you giggle along
but you didn't know what the [ __ ] what
they were saying you know saying like
you giggle ah
you sucked a [ __ ] and then you had to
go home and find out what [ __ ] was you
should
ask somebody [ __ ] older than you
what's going on lisa you look a little
disturbed no my cam counselor was the
first time i saw like an actual porn
magazine from him yeah and i took he had
had a whole walker in the cabin with it
and i took literally one page home had
four signs
i took one page home and hidden under
the mattress and my mom found it and i
jerk off in the class that guy never won
the way he could just cup your dick
and she's gonna run around here a little
[ __ ] no i stopped when i was like in the
eighth grade what a waste
it's not what wearing underwear oh what
a waste what do you mean where did the
drips go i didn't like it what about
your last drips they were going through
the jeans and the jeans smells like a
[ __ ] holly goat i don't know
there were some as i take off my pants
and my pants smells so [ __ ] [ __ ]
mad
i remember going to an ac dc concert in
fact yesterday i'm sitting at the
[ __ ] coffee shop writing and this kid
walks in
and i can't see without my glasses
and he walks to the counter and i look
at his shirt and this is back in black
1980 tour and on the back at all the
cities and the kids i was sitting with i
go yo hey
can you do me a favor come here for a
second i go to my friend
july 31st
spectrum philadelphia august 1st new
york city palladium i go look at this
shirt
he goes you're [ __ ] dead on like wow
i remember i went to that [ __ ]
concert
at the palladium that was back in black
tour ac dc the second night of the tour
who opened uh
def leppard wow
def leppard with the dry tour
unbelievable right there at the
palladium right i heard that this is
dorms now at nyu no way they made it
into dorms for nyu the palladium was
like [ __ ]
an institution yeah in the 50s and 60s
that's where all the jewish men went on
the weekends to hit on the puerto rican
chick
if you looked at anything from the
palladium or what's the place there
where's the palladium the palladium was
on downtown somewhere if you want to
look it up the old palladium but you
know where else jews hung out remember
the place where
uh
henry hill takes the chick yeah the
spanish club on on the upper west side
oh yeah that was another big they coming
from long island the jews would pick up
on the puerto rican chicks and cheat on
their wives and [ __ ] and eat pork chops
and [ __ ]
what happens in manhattan stays in my
head
east 14th between
uh
irving place and third oh that's right
by me yeah that's where wait that's
where webster hall is then is that that
website around there no he's 14th no no
no
that nate that place the palladium i saw
a judas priest yeah that's god that is
dorms now
yeah i saw ozzy osbourne there i saw
james brown i saw you two there
i saw i think i saw nazareth there wow i
saw a bunch of [ __ ] bands in there as
a kid then they turned it into club mtv
huh club mtv was a dance show on mtv
that came on at three o'clock bunch of
[ __ ] kids from the city
it was like soul train without the black
people just a bunch of like little white
kids from the [ __ ] upper west side
dancing
doing the [ __ ] robot and whatnot it
was crazy
that was a hot little part of town man
remember years ago like in the 80s early
80s
and you know all those places where you
guys live at now but just dumps that's
where you went to get heroin you know
but the hot clubs would open up there
because nobody would think of going down
there you know so all the hot clubs
i went to this club down there one time
on the lower east side
but a few blocks away they had italian
style chinese food what they have
italian too this was dead this is this
is 84. this is a restaurant i don't know
the name was popular at the time
and i went there that place always had
like cool little spots since i was a kid
you know delancy street do you know
where that is now delancey street yeah
yeah how close are you to it like i
walked there is it still very yiddish
very hasidic jewish ooh delancey i feel
like it's almost chinatown yeah they
changed it all up when i was a kid
delancey street was all uh no it's not
really that yiddish maybe it's something
it was all [ __ ] uh hasidic jews and
this old stuff
so if you want to get sneakers like good
sneakers a good deal yeah like nobody
else negotiated with young congress
but delancey street they negotiated with
you but you could give them not the
actual store price yeah you could go in
and go how about 22.50 and they go [ __ ]
you 24 everybody come on 23.
but they had a rule that if you were the
first customer of the day they had to do
business with you
always our goal we should jewish
superstition yeah like yeah i said
superstitions
chinese have the same thing if you walk
in there first as a customer they have
to do business with you
it just sets the tone for the rest of
the day so i would go in there and get a
like in those days i would buy
how much would you lowball them and be
like five dollars
what happened was when limousines for
the feet came in they were like [ __ ]
they were like a movie theater they were
like a ticket no you couldn't get them
anymore so jersey ran out of them so me
and my friends were hip to this yeah so
we go to delancey street knock off two
dollars attack on a fin and hey
when you're in the air you're right
seven dollars is seven [ __ ] dollars
huge seven dollars was a pair of coach
cons coach cons were the ones that
weren't converse not chuck taylors
they're the ones if your mother didn't
have the four dollars
because chuck taylors were always 7.99
no chuck schumer 79 chuck taylors were
11.99 they're like 35 now easy 35
sometimes 45. if you want with the good
souls when i came from cuba 65 taylor's
with 1095 and coach cons
what are coach coach cons were the ones
underneath
them under less than chuck taylor's less
than chuck what are coach and they had
stars on the bottom of your sneaker
underneath so instead of trading stars
yeah
so you had coach cons you have pf flyers
and people
and you had kids kedz was the big
[ __ ] shoe
but converse was beating the [ __ ] up
chuck taylor was [ __ ] people over
here they had that song yeah chuck
taylors were [ __ ] people up for years
there was nothing like a pair of white
chuck taylors
and people now would complain about
chuck taylors because they would say
that there's not enough support yeah i
have white feet i can never have i grew
up in chuck taylor they got the better
ones now with the better soldiers they
touched you up but you can order them
online and make them however you want
them whatever converse
yeah chuck taylor's originals those
those aren't even owned by converse
anymore i think reebok owns it i didn't
think nike had them before and people
eventually just sell it off and someone
else is like i'll buy it from you
because it's always going to make some
money because everyone wants some
[ __ ] julia serving limousines for the
feet so then
everybody had a pro head's commercial
every link everybody had chuck taylors
yeah everybody had chucked out chuck
taylor i was a basketball in high school
i didn't know in games and then when
[ __ ] julia's serving yeah went over
to the sixers
the converse paid them they know the
sisters gave him six million dollars but
congress gave him like another three and
they devised the shoe around he was the
first guy that had the shoe right oh
so this was the first shoe that came
from that these shoes were sold out
the kink to these shoes were when you
bought them yeah if you opened up the
box real quick because there was a pass
in there
for uh for what
do those things move now they do these
little like yeah yeah right there that's
crazy 1981 shoe commercial see if that's
it video's unavailable
that's good
home to my converse all-star basketball
shoes
you're the greatest that's no jive your
standard equipment on the b street five
as i fly through the air doing my famous
slam dunk i'm flying first class and
that ain't no bump my shoes will be
wearing the converse name till
those background guys are hilarious look
at those now reacting converse history
part one ooh dr jay and and bird yeah
click it okay
yeah watch this see that's
gonna be good i had those weapons those
those worthy weapons
i had those they cut up your feet though
but
yeah those right there weapons
but i had those way more i had those
when they were
there those were the ones
oh the conversation
from
my childhood you know all the way
through
oh [ __ ] associated since 1974 better
than 30 years and it's been happy
happy experience look at that [ __ ]
every time i step on the floor it's
important that uh that i go out there
and i represent you know the history of
commerce in 1908 marquee converse
founded the converse rubber shoe company
in mauldin look at this [ __ ]
manufacturer winterized rubber
everything in boston moving to satisfy a
growing need in the u.s for basketball
shoes converse created the all-star in
1917. shortly thereafter a young man
approached the company with some fresh
new ideas and history would soon be made
chuck taylor joined the company in in
1921 and he walked into
a sales office in chicago with really a
set of ideas on how he thought that shoe
could perform better one of them was the
the famous patch which is on the inside
ankle of the shoe he wanted to protect
players ankles so that actually used to
be a sewn on leather patch well marquis
converse the founder of the company was
so impressed with what he'd done to
improve the product
that he put chuck's name on the product
in 1923. from that day on chuck sort of
became the ambassador of basketball in
america he's kind of a johnny appleseed
of basketball others used by other
companies existed on the market the
all-star was a true phenomenon
outfitting teams from coast to coast the
chuck taylor all-star was the shoe for
decades although in retrospect they may
not have been the most comfortable for
the newly developing fast break style of
basketball we have to remember that all
the shoes that i was there the [ __ ]
bob
that bad [ __ ] black canvas high
tops
uh now that i look back on them since
they were the only option we had hey
that's what we wore
a leader in basketball shoe sales the
chuck taylor was joined in popularity by
the jack purcell model first produced
for tennis and badminton in the 1930s
they brought that back for the top
badminton champion of the era the jack
purcell brand soon became oh my god
these are the kind of sports stars they
had before they had the badminton hero
yeah the brand received a big lift when
photos of james dean relaxing in the low
canvas shoe were released with dean
looking slightly cooler in jack
purcell's than in his high school chuck
taylor all-stars back on the hardwood
converse continued to dominate the
basketball landscape chuck taylor spread
the converse word through countless
all-white all-white players
bill russell back down
chuck taylor was inducted into the
basketball hall of fame hell yeah
he ate the same induction class as red
auerbach
well the owner of the hall finds dozens
of examples of converse influence
throughout the history of the sport from
college the nba
and even overseas all the greats we're
wearing and everybody from bob cousy of
course bill russell got all his rings
wearing them and
and everybody wore that shoe look at
that it wasn't official
official shoe of the nba for so much
time with the introduction of leather
basketball shoes in the late 60s the
chuck taylor all stars were appreciated
in the athletic realm although it's
popular he wore pumas
reach expanded beyond basketball they
also had success in the sports of tennis
dog football
yeah i didn't know kama's been around
that [ __ ] long that's a long time
chuck taylor i never really julius
julius took it to the next [ __ ] level
with the limousines for the feet
that's what those were those were
leather shoes and then they started
adding the color to it and the [ __ ]
glitter but besides that
they're the original limousines for the
features i like how they thought the
patches protect people's ankles did you
see that
dog no
oh my god look at those legs look how
long those [ __ ] legs are on the
stripes
watch a second to show the commercial
you're gonna die
look at that
his influence and
he's gonna show me the commercial it's a
seven minute video
what the [ __ ] look at this oh jesus
jesus christ in hell jesus christ right
in this face look at that was billy paul
unnecessary yeah that he did that to a
bunch of intentional disrespect there
and then
when i and then michael jordan took it
from there
you could turn this off now no julia
serving would do some nasty [ __ ]
things to you when we're on the rogan
podcast a couple weeks ago yeah i told
him to put on julius irving's top 10
dunks dude that behind the backboard
that had to be in there even though it
wasn't a dunk going around behind the
bathroom reaching back in and just
looking back up i was against the lakers
wow he was a laker killer back in the
day put that one on if you watch it it
was just crazy the top ten dunks by
julia serving there was a dunk on here
yeah that nobody ever talks about but i
think it is one of the greatest dunks of
all time what and i saw it live what he
did in the port against the portland
trail base of the finals when they lost
that on six games in game six
they were losing like by 11
and they were kind of iffy iffy and
julius irving wanted to make a statement
and he took the ball and he drove it and
he slammed it and built walton's face
like bill wharton was the big thing then
he just slammed i'll show it to you that
you see bill walton calling for an
offensive foul
okay put the music on
man i can't believe
[Applause]
that's the one you're talking about no
that's not what i'm talking about look
at this one this one's beautiful
boom right here kareem palming the ball
get the [ __ ] out he had that first step
man
oh [ __ ]
wow
oh that's detroit who's not gonna let
him score ever he is such an exciting
get lakers again always kill the lakers
look at him
god he jumped high
look at that move
yeah you're right the first step you
take by his first step
he went around the back to turn that
guy's face
and then dunked
i love that guy i love that guy
that's against [ __ ] when he palms
that basketball there's no getting it
out of his hand
jesus that's against the phoenix suns
and that was walter davis and the coke
heads look at those two giants next to
him look at him right now how good you
have to be the slam that way
what here we go against it here we go
against port watch bill walton one two
one bam look at bill what call for the
offensive watch bill walton comes up
look at the watch
watch watch no calling for the offensive
oh what a [ __ ] punk this is another
one against that against you ready to
jump into it look at this one this
that's in the same game too oh
that's against bobby gross
no he didn't [ __ ] around dawg
look at this one i had this game getting
one point at all and i was at the game
he windmills in his face were you really
i was at that game
i was at that i was getting a point at
home look at this
that's when you knew they were gonna win
it that year look up dr j around the
backboard
wow
yeah he was exposing that first step he
would just shake you and go he would
hold that ball and his right hip or his
left hip depending on where he was
standing
and he would take that first step and
juke it and then bring it back
and that's why you hold it he would just
palm it and while you were going back
with him he would take off he had it
perfectly timed it's 89.84 there you go
what the [ __ ] unbelievable
[Applause]
are they going to play a super slow
motion i guess is that what they're
doing right now look at that one hand
are you doing that are they they're
doing that oh look at this oh
who's that in the middle jabbar thinking
about it oh lakers he goes up but he's
behind the backboard he's playing a long
way yes
and the head's almost going to hit it he
ducks
his head and now he's going backwards
yes
backwards this is brilliant and he just
reaches out this is brilliant you see
that white dude over there with the 60s
shirt on yeah 24 bobby jones that guy
was a [ __ ] defensive savage wow
that's crazy look at he was white
jumping over a five-point game and he
was jumping over kareem that dude bobby
gro uh
bobby jones was a white dude that was a
[ __ ] tremendous [ __ ] defensive
player okay here's the best duck i ever
remember being at i don't know he'll be
there dr j i'm sorry jerry stackhouse
university of maryland
against two throwing down universe
against the university of maryland
and he caught an ally you passed it and
everybody was like oh that's just a bad
pass and then he just went up so high to
get it and threw it down so hard
if it's like i remember
many of the it dunks i ever seen beside
julia serving was michael jordan in
college against like wake forest on a
saturday afternoon yeah when he called
the clear one and he just went down and
[ __ ] annihilated that guard
i love dunks i [ __ ] love them they're
great they make everybody go crazy 100
percentage percentage uh why are they
hacky dunks yeah no they're not hacky
was it 95 maybe ari for jerry saccos
yeah yeah yeah it very well might have
been is it just one dunk
no not the whole game no i know
that's an hour and a half oh
i keep hearing music yeah someone's
playing a recorder or something
uh jerry i know it's crazy wait put dunk
on that too in the search
it's like some something with an organ
or something like that like a
like a [ __ ] tutor whatever yeah
someone's playing and someone's playing
like [ __ ] immigrant dunk
oh i mean uh music
yeah i think we have to find the whole
game okay go downstairs go downstairs
let me just see
oh that's youtube damn it
all right i don't know where it is
i'd love to see it again though
they're like that's like even for
someone who could never play bad i don't
even know the rules of basketball as a
kid the dunks or the best part the best
part they would show time more back then
too they would go for it they'd give the
fans a little something
right they wouldn't just go in and just
dunk it they would like hey i'm gonna
[ __ ] windmill here it wasn't called
showboating it was [ __ ] showboating
people enjoyed it like yeah showboat
we're all [ __ ] fans
do a crazy dunk what happened was and
then they just start having respect the
nba had and the aba were
opposite scenes and all sudden
the aba went into like this dunk mode
yeah they had
george girvin and julia serving and
uh involving bad news barnes they went
into this [ __ ]
other type of mode entertainment in the
nba ticket sales started going down like
there's a whole story aba ticket sales
start going no nba ticket sales started
going down aba ticket sales were always
bad in different cities and [ __ ]
but they were talking about how at one
point with the nba it got so
chuck and jive as they want to call they
got two black yeah you know let's be
honest with what the word was they got
two black and white sale that's when you
watch that bird
against celtics remember a couple weeks
ago they had that series celtics against
the lakers on espn it was a whole
week-long thing that's why larry bird
was so important
because the league was the the sales
were
low
white people weren't going to games
so that's why larry bird meant was so
much you know you guys were really young
when larry bird came on the scene
it was like bruce lee
it was like bruce lee guys
and you cheered for this [ __ ] ugly
looking white dude
they wouldn't they were 9-0 indiana
state was 9-0 and i don't know what they
are i don't know if they're division two
or
or three but they wouldn't get on tv
yeah and everybody kept talking about
this white dude 30 points a game
averaging 33 points a game a 31 college
league no nation in scoring that team is
9-0 they wouldn't [ __ ] show indiana
state and finally by the 11th game
they showed indiana state and larry bird
put on a clinic in front of the country
and that was it after that every sunday
we don't give a [ __ ] of ucla is playing
usc
acc gang you know the acc is a popular
[ __ ] maryland yeah north carolina
that's
gone maryland's yeah that's always been
my favorite one of my favorite that in
the big east yeah those two those two
were basketball college basketball yeah
for sure
for sure they were
it was just a [ __ ] so when bird came
up
it was such a big deal because he was
going to put asses and seats again
you know he went away from the dunk he
was popping 30 [ __ ] footers
so he went back to the game so that's
why it was so important and then they
developed a rivalry with larry brown
with magic johnson did you guys watch
reggie miller play because i love
three-pointers but
everyone who shoots them from whenever
i'm watching seems to miss like seven
like seven out of ten so it gets
annoying because they keep missing but
reggie miller
he's the best of his lifetime stats he
was fire he would re if he got an inch
he was the steph curry
there was a game against the knicks
where he hit a three the game was over
then he hit a three
stole the inbounds pass i think went for
two
and then
the next inbound pass he like stole
again and just backed up and hit a three
it was like eight points in 15 seconds
and then just the game just changed it
was over it was done the other way look
up look up that you remember that
when reggie miller was the only thing
keeping the knicks out of the playoffs
yeah he was an echo and [ __ ] spike
and he's throwing the spike lee's face
who chokes now [ __ ] as spike lee
used to say [ __ ] to him and he used to
say [ __ ] back three-point field goal
percentage forty percent
thirty nine point five percent yeah
spike lee would jump back in his face
you know who i am
you know what i can do to you so that
was this guy when i was coming up that
those 16 seconds maybe you remember
see if there's a video for this cat name
lloyd free
just put lloyd free
when i was a kid lloyd free i thought
lloyd free was gonna be the best player
in the league lloyd free okay
merchant
right there world be free yeah then he
changed his name to world be free the
legend
click on that one yeah
he played for the sixes
all right but when he came into the
league yeah he was like johnny ghetto
they would only put him in
way before he was world
way before this [ __ ]
when he came into the sixes they said he
could shoot the ball him and i'm balding
that way that's great him and andrew
tony can shoot the ball in the dark
watch these shots
look how he was built to boot
strong
no this kid was a savage yeah stocky
he's like a
but when he was with the sixers with
julia serving
that one season when they'd be down 13
points going into the half and he was
the sixth man damn what a nice yeah yeah
this guy was badass he come off the
bench
for the
yeah no this guy was a savage look at
when he was a sixer he was tremendous
with a chain on that's flopping out yeah
he didn't give a [ __ ] a nice dish look
unselfish
what nice yeah dawg this guy was a
smooth smooth then he changed his name
to world be free and it was over
yeah i thought he was a lot better when
he was lloyd be free he was kicking
white people he didn't give a [ __ ]
there was two players i thought they
were phenomenal look at this
and he was tough like he took it to your
ass if you [ __ ] with him
if you didn't respect his defense like
if you didn't go out to play him
he would pop a 40 on you he could pop a
40 on your dog
wow cool
and then put another guy in this was my
all-time favorite this guy used to come
off the bench for the seattle
supersonics
who
who
he was built like me
yeah and he'd drink on the bench that
he'd have a little brown bag on the
bench
and the coach would yell from like if
they were down like four points the
coach would pop his said you really
going coach i go in but there ain't no
defense coming out of me he was a little
chubby dude
i forget what his name is now he'd take
the ball dribble it twice and just throw
it up in the air bam he'd do that three
or four times
they'd be up and he said coach it's over
i've tired myself out i gotta get a beer
[Laughter]
it was is it weird for you that like
great teams aren't around anymore like
when you say like the seattle
supersonics there's people listening to
this podcast who probably never saw them
play yeah they've been gone for a while
now the seattle super sevens had a great
team
shock years were good sean kemp peyton
years were really good yeah but before
that great nba jam team the great nba
gym team they [ __ ] uh way before that
they went to the finals or maybe even
won it one year with jack sigma
and a bunch of [ __ ] crazy dudes i was
a kid i used to love all that [ __ ] that
was my world
it was all that basketball you know i
still remember when the bullets were in
washington yeah with that one bar the
one black dude that was [ __ ]
tremendous
haywood workman was a great defender
yes on sale was great yeah but until
they said bobby had one of the best
first steps
of anyone and and he was short and stuck
and they had uh
and he played with bernard king's little
brother albert albert king and they said
albert king had such a quick first step
that he would fake you out then go back
and then come back to the original spot
but you couldn't have even reacted to
the first fake so you're still going so
sometimes he'd fake my himself into
tougher defense
you know cause like i put you that way
you're supposed to try to go back but
it's like i couldn't even see that
yeah compared to his brother bernard
king was the better one
put on bernard king highlights let me
tell you something about bernard king
all right and you're listening to your
[ __ ] older brother here yeah it was
tony soprano
it was jackie gleason there was lawrence
taylor
and this guy came in a tight third
right there this kid
came those are cool oh my god this guy
was a nightmare when he first came out
of college
look at [ __ ] red on round ball
man that's red on round ball that's that
used to be halftime of all the nba games
right on round ball he would teach you
how to play basketball really light that
up put that out loud
six foot six look at this [ __ ]
dog what
what
brother bernard
yeah cause he played inside right look
at him look at him boom boom oh my god
nice spin oh no he had the best spin i
knew not king as an older no
but king was i knew him was the greatest
listen they did a 30 for 30 odds
they did a 30 for 30 on them recently
if he wouldn't have got hurt he's still
number eight in all-time scoring
and he got hurt three years his knees
like this guy
he was a [ __ ] savage and he was the
king of new york look at him when he
played in new york at that garden on a
tuesday look at where he used to have to
cover he used to have to cover savages
look at his face look at him he was a
[ __ ] yeah he was tough right
tough yeah i remember him there with the
bullets little older
best player yeah look at him against
detroit against mark aguirre he didn't
give up look at kelly chapucca but kelly
chapucca that that dude you play for
[ __ ] jersey and he you know how most
players have a thousand points four
years ago
yeah this guy was bad that's why he's
like you're supposed to be out in the
wing he's like what are you doing
playing the pivot look at him i guess
look at he didn't give a [ __ ] he never
got the memo like most people get the
memo you know that's a play he didn't
give a [ __ ]
and he took a tv he got right into your
chest look at where he got him he took
it to your ass and always and won
look at him in new york he was just
tremendous as a nick
but now look at him
he would [ __ ] you up from anywhere
that's artist gilmore and billy
pulse look at brother bernard
oh [ __ ]
there wasn't even a three point oh
that's that's oh my god
so now he's getting older
no by the time he got to the bullets he
was done yeah his knees were done
they said the night he got hurt look at
him in tennessee the bernie and [ __ ]
ernie show straight from [ __ ]
brooklyn jack look at him
straight out of [ __ ] brooklyn this
[ __ ] bernard
and then that's
then he went to the nets and he got in
trouble with the nest they caught him
out of lights falling asleep with
cocaine on his shirt
so they sent them to rehab and the
golden state warriors and while he was
at the warriors he became the comeback
player of the year and then guess what
what the knicks kind of came a calling
from and that was the [ __ ] beginning
of the ending oh yeah no no no that year
when he when he got out of rehab he went
bananas he went [ __ ] bananas he went
to rehab for a year for six months six
weeks wow and then he went to golden
state he went and he wanted to come back
look at the new york city new york city
don't give it to a black dude like that
ever look at him he didn't give a [ __ ]
look at him
bam
[Music]
look at those stock brokers after work
getting [ __ ] up
nope don't defend that
paul westfall oh my god i forgot he was
a nick
that dude could shoot the boy he was
ambidextrous he could pop a 30 on you
with both hands dog you understand me
yeah he [ __ ] up the
he [ __ ] up the sixes he [ __ ] up
everybody
one week he scored 60 points in two
games against the celtics and somebody
else at the garden
and that was it look at him look at him
he didn't stop dog wow
that's the garden dog i love how they're
dressing in the stands that's new york
[ __ ] city are if you didn't get them
off their feet like that on a tuesday
night are you [ __ ] crazy man come on
you know how many tuesday nights i went
into that [ __ ] garden just to watch
him play
there he goes 50 points
geez
oh every time he gets up at this point
he's just [ __ ] hurting
all right here it is but i'm looking for
50. he's got it
i'm telling you he was he had a couple
nights he was just popping just give me
the ball i can't miss right now
bernard takes it to the hoop yes and it
counts
nobody can stop this [ __ ]
not detroit
wow i'm telling you guys you have no
idea i wouldn't [ __ ] [ __ ] you
guys this is as good as it gets for a
long time
he was [ __ ] up the celtics he was
[ __ ] up to sixes
he was [ __ ] and that dude he was
hugging right that little brother right
there ray williams he had a brother
called gus williams that played for the
seattle supersonics that was also a
[ __ ] they used to call him the
and it wizards bernard king continues to
hammer those dislocated fingers on both
hands
here's king
yes
there's king
over curator yes
king with a sensational rebound
damn
no tremendous brother tremendous [ __ ]
i grew up with this [ __ ] it was that
that kitty played against i remember one
night irish affair yeah my high school
was in the semi-finals
of the states i was a basketball geek
me the coach from ramapo chucking
mcbreen whitey o'donnell we hopped on
the bus and we went out to [ __ ] in uh
broomfield new jersey
to watch our high school against this
white dude that was a machine
his father had been a quarterback for
the broncos yeah and this kid is you
know most players have a thousand points
in four years
yeah he was doing a thousand a year
really oh they said he was the next
julia serving and he was white i went
out there the kid's name was kelly
chapuca no way
we're sitting at the [ __ ] you saw him in
high school oh my god listen to me
against my high school he scored 44
points wow he was 20 for 24 from the
field wow
we beat him
with a tipping this kid called the veto
that was about he had gone to like eight
different colleges he had gone for like
eight different high schools he was
originally from north bergen but he went
to like union hill emerson then he made
a comeback at north park
and then north berlin there he had like
one year eligibility left
but he was a [ __ ] savage called the
veto
and there was like a ball was on the rim
and he tipped it in our high school one
then we had to play camden
in [ __ ] camden down there and that's
when we had a coach that was in a
wheelchair ralphie mourinho yeah and we
beat the camden and the one black kid
came over and spit in his [ __ ] face
who spits the guy's face in a wheelchair
crazy
[ __ ] crazy man
how crazy were the stands back then
because now like even though even the
bleachers are kind of tame this is my
favorite video that i've ever seen is
when they threw pizza at a guy's face at
fenway that one still makes me laugh but
when i went to old redskins games or
bullets games it was like it shook like
it was like this isn't sturdy
everyone's stomping and it's going crazy
and it's like it was not that safe i
went to a lot of games surprised i
didn't all fall i missed a lot of games
of everything
and i'm gonna tell you the loudest
stadium i was ever in how i thought
there was an earthquake
but i was scared for a few minutes but
they couldn't be an earthquake there
yeah ready for this monday night
football
when [ __ ] joe montana went to kansas
city
and they played against the denver
broncos on monday night and joe i think
it was joe montana was about to take him
into the [ __ ]
i'd never been in a place as loud as
that and there was an earthquake there
was a [ __ ] earthquake
that was a [ __ ] earthquake man
i love that i love that that's why it's
so disappointing when you go to some
place and they don't have like a great
fan experience
like that's why it's so much it's so
much fun
i don't know it's
and then and then like that's why i like
older stadiums i like i've sat in very
nice stolen still but yeah i like older
like that's the one my one baseball
regret is i wish i had gone to the old
yankee stadium that would have been fun
to see yankee stadium
it was 1990s
excuse me summer in 93
and i saw [ __ ] crack violence on the
steps no way yeah
it was [ __ ] crazy and that wasn't
really a big yankee stadium guy i was
always a shea stadium guy because my mom
was a met fan
but i so i went to some [ __ ] listen
man
sports
changed a lot i mean i remember going to
a game at the houston to watch clements
pitch yeah against somebody and nobody
would nobody would yell
nobody would talk
people would say things but amongst
themselves you really couldn't
say anything aloud i used to go to games
with my mother
she used to throw chicken wings at rusty
stop
what they banned my mother from sitting
on right field and made her sit on left
field
throw a [ __ ] chicken
the right fielder from the mets because
he made an error one day my mom lost a
bet
so she never forgave that [ __ ]
ever again
so every time she run by my mother will
call him
and she start yelling at him and
throwing chicken wings at him so
they liked my mom so they said listen
you can still come to the games just
gotta sit on the left field or some [ __ ]
the opposite side
but people were crazy people yelled
people had fist fights i went to a jet
philly game one time in
new jersey in 1993.
yeah i'll never forget that some dude
had like a new england jacket on or
something
and they kept telling take the jacket
off
take the jacket off and the guy got up
thought he was cute turned around and
went like this with his fingers then
turned back around
ari shafia he wasn't he wasn't to here
and things were being projectiled at him
from everywhere from hot dogs to sodas
to beers
to [ __ ] popcorn everyone's just
talking about people just chucking [ __ ]
at them so bad that security had to come
and pull them out like um
[Laughter]
that's the [ __ ] i miss
i don't like going listen i don't like
when lee tells me he's going to a dodger
game in the back of my mind i think at
least i'm getting beat up
he goes to a dodger game with a boston
red sox depends on where i'm sitting and
some [ __ ] jerk off says something to
you you know
don't don't i don't need that in the
game that's not what games were about
ever ever
games were about i don't know you you
don't know me but you know what man you
got a joint let's spark it i got one too
yeah and next you know the whole area is
pissed off kids mothers with their kids
are looking at us [ __ ] you put away the
marijuana [ __ ] you
that's what baseball games used to be
when like when your team is coming back
or when you're like your team hits a
home run it's the same thing as like
when the whole table gets like the
dealer bus on blackjack like like it's
the same everyone's tied together
yeah it's it's
uh it's a lot of fun it stinks when they
lose
but it's like that i i don't think
there's a better sport than baseball to
see live i don't know i don't know so
slow you can go out have drinks yeah
yeah yeah you can walk around you get
some sun it's like [ __ ] it's just so
nice it's such a pleasant experience
like right now nothing matters if you're
up to two runs to nothing you're like
well we can miss this offensive you know
go get some [ __ ] something down below
and this is the time of the year to go
watch baseball school's back in session
still warm september the nights here in
los angeles are [ __ ] gorgeous yeah
nights in new york evenings in new york
look at the yankees schedule
i want to see if they have one more
weekday day game those weekday day games
they're fun brother nobody's there
nobody's there
you get the stink sandwich there yet
yeah i can say that yeah the twenty-one
steak sandwich i don't think i have is
that worth it [ __ ] you've had that
i've heard from steak sandwich
professionals there that have said that
they go there just for the steak
sandwich really yeah i'll go i'll get it
maybe it's a houston's me something like
that you think i'm scared my friend used
to leave in the seventh inning he's got
a steak sandwich oh i've seen that steak
sandwich up there where he's hit it
yes you have to go somewhere and get it
he says it's [ __ ] out of this world
really
um and that's one thing stadium food has
become like what was it decent dogs bro
well dodger stadium
dog garbage they have chinese food now
well it's not angel stadium has panda
express right [ __ ] uh memorial
stadium no camden yards that kosher food
they had a kosher stand yeah where the
orioles yeah but didn't i eat at boot
pals playstation
yeah there's a truck outside right yeah
yes this was inside the gates though
yeah i had tickets to the game i went in
i got some it's like barbecue beef or
like brisket or something yeah i don't
give a [ __ ]
they get called to that [ __ ] face
turns red i'm doing a [ __ ]
podcast jack [ __ ] that you're supposed
to call me this morning pit beef boot
pals pit beef pit beef
pit beef and balm wars
damn
so many places have a good high mouth
water
i miss like a good [ __ ] crab cake
i really had those you know like crab
cake type of guy from that kosher for
too long so i didn't uh so if you eat
kosher you can't eat crabs
no shellfish it's not even the way you
make it just crabs at all no crabs
what's his name barry [ __ ] what's his
name lobster yeah no one keeps kosher no
uh what's his name the guy that went
away that robbed everybody
that deniro played on hbo oh um
recently that guy oh oh this made off
yeah made off
yeah he wasn't keeping kosher yeah no
one keeps kosher you're also not
supposed to lie and cheat people out of
money but like because of the bigger
issues than what he's [ __ ] putting in
his throat
it's one of the ten man well that's why
i made the point
i don't even worry about [ __ ] putting
people into homelessness he cares too
much about like is this permitted
it'd be pretty funny if he was keeping
kosher he just keeping coaches the whole
time like no god wants it like what
about bilking people
well we fall it
falls into a loophole no shellfish at
all no shellfish no lobster no ham no
pork so there's none of that pork no
cheese with meat so there's no
cheeseburgers yeah you can't mix well
how the [ __ ] do you eat 20 cheeseburgers
a week because i don't keep going he's
making up for lost time he orders twice
the cheese i'll tell him he'll let you
know when he stops now what's good
that's kosher now like they turned a lot
of food no you know you can get you can
get kosher food now yeah cats are all
kosher
all nestle is kosher
so you're good on the candy front uh
most gummies kosher
uh technically because they kind of the
horse hoof is not even any kind of meat
so they're like so it doesn't matter is
it really horse off yeah it's horse off
what's washed off the stuff that makes
the gummy texture they're shaving down
horse
they're just like they're just like yeah
sanding it down until it's a powder and
using that as a mix oh nice okay so
normally that wouldn't be kosher but the
jewish
board of rabbis like that ain't even
food you can eat horse hoof that's not
even about kosher or not so
that's allowed you can have spaghetti
and meatballs you can't put parmesan
cheese on there
they do have bacon bits which are fake
bacon or fakeos
i had bacon it goes yeah which tastes
like bacon bits you can put on a salad
tastes like bacon work around and
[ __ ] fried chicken absolutely not
but you can make fried chicken at home
keep in mind you have two parents almost
every time
really taking care of you
so
plenty of time to cook
uh make me something nice please but
then you haven't made don't you have to
have two sets of dishes two sets of
dishes you gotta have meat on one side
milk another now if you're a ball in a
family you get two dishwashers
generally if you're poor you have no
dishwashers you gotta get separate sinks
ish
you can use the same sink but you gotta
use different sponges for meat dishes or
milk dishes now what's a kosher chicken
for do
kill no no nothing you gotta go to uh
you gotta go to a jewish uh
whatever they're called butcher butcher
yeah they gotta be killed in a certain
way and blessed right through it right
through a hole in your thing exactly in
between two vertebrae
there's no pain yeah which is now by the
way way more inhumane than what they
actually just do now what everybody does
before they would just beat him to death
and said the jews like oh we should be
better than that but now they're just
worse than
they just [ __ ] kill them they're done
with an instant electrocution but like
uh so they kill it perfectly if they
[ __ ] up you can't you can have it we
can't have it anymore they're gonna sell
it uh wholesale to the [ __ ]
um you know so it's not a total loss
yeah we don't we don't waste it yeah why
waste it
and then if it is killed then you're
fine but if it comes in contact with
with uh milk you're [ __ ] right you'll
get kosher milk is fine just not with
meat
only only fish is the is the universal
donor that can go with meat or milk
fish is fine somehow they don't believe
fish are real animals they don't have to
kill those you can just swallow them
alive
no rules about it
yeah crazy i didn't know that much oh
yeah now what about sushi sushi is
allowed just not like you couldn't
salmon sushi totally good what no philly
roll no philly roll why not because of
the cream cheese yeah no no you can have
kosher cream cheese no but not what the
philadelphia brand cream cheese is
kosher cream cheese not with what oh
with the salmon with the salmon you can
oh you're absolutely right you can have
a philly roll you can't have it uh
that's the crab roll
you can't have that at that california
roll but you can have the imitation crab
meat that's the california roll the
imitation crab meat right
yeah you could have that you could have
the salmon the spicy salmon see i didn't
know fish and dairy snapper
you can have that yeah and with the with
my dad makes my dad makes it now now
what about get into it does meat have to
be kosher meat has to be kosher awesome
everything except trash
if it's kosher now pigs they'll never be
kosher
giraffes yes
horses i forget now let me ask you this
where's the jewish butcher around here
in the valley yeah there's a few oh you
can get some kishka dude i made a
challenge did i tell you that you did
with the girl yeah okay it came out
great i was up here or something for the
kishka because you gotta get that frozen
it came out great
we gotta make a we gotta make a chunk
before i leave you got a crock pot
i think so i gotta ask my wife i don't
know what ask her
it's a it's a 16-hour dish tell them
tell them what it is it's like the stew
it's it's a eastern european stew i
don't think i've ever had chilland why
who raised you not i guess not eastern
either eastern european i don't know
what's your last name science yeah i
don't know what that is that sounds a
little arabic uh no it's uh lithuanian
okay that should be okay you should then
you should have chillin i'm sure we do
somewhere beans
barley okay potato like just you know
diced potatoes
all sorts of different things in
different regions some people put like
chopped up
wiener dogs
which is fine whatever for garbage so to
put hard-boiled eggs in there kishko
over the top
which is just intestine tubes and they
bake so good
oh they baked so good no i'm i think i'm
too far down and you put water in it and
you put it in a crock pot on on low or
medium i forget for 16 hours you do it
at like
6 p.m you set it you forget it you come
back the next day at lunch
first maybe you get a little a little
mixture because the steam keeps it keeps
it watery you know you don't let the top
off too much that's will dry out but you
get one
for breakfast before you go to uh shul
because you're gonna be there for a few
hours so you smell it so you're like let
me just get a bite of this so you
quickly eat a little bit put the top
back on and then at 11 30 12 they take
it off and it's got this consistency
which is not like wet can we put
shredded beef from that [ __ ] we
put also instead of yeah the hot dogs
we could put with the potatoes they put
brisket brisket pieces of brisket
they put um these uh these these ribs
that have the you know the squares in
the inside the bones whatever those are
called
and then they melt off the bones just
come out and then the marrow goes out
into the things so you eat these [ __ ]
you can bottom out the marrow from these
bones because the meat comes off yeah
you can put shredded beef that sounds
nice with some brisket of that now
brisket is kosher correct yeah brisket's
kosher you get that from anywhere though
or that has to be chilling you probably
still have to have it be a kosher
bircher like if you go to this oh yeah
place up here in north hollywood yeah
brisket yeah that wouldn't be because
okay they have to have
a rabbi looking over the process or
threatening to look over the process so
we can trust you that you're actually
doing it right
now what's the nearest holiday the first
holiday the jewish season is now coming
rosh hashanah new year's
which is september
24th maybe i don't know
how is this track it's early this year
huh
it is
yeah it's totally the same 20th it
starts september 20th yes
really yes september 10th so yes
10 days of
repentance
so on rosh hashanah
first day of the holidays god opens up
his book
it's like santa claus
let's see what you've been up to
and he makes his judgments about you
but he keeps the book open
so you got ten days on the first day of
rosh hashanah second day of roshana then
seven days in between and then the last
day is yom kippur that's all there's no
family get together russian of this
family get together you eat apples
dipped in honey you remember that you do
that oh yeah that's yeah apples dipped
in honey round challah instead of long
one circle hollow because then the re
the year is round can i ask you a
question yeah sure are you a raisin
hollow or a plain hollow person dude we
would go one and one because i love
raisin challah especially
yeah but so we have for everybody and if
you want three out of four one way but
you feel like taking you know a jump
then take the jump that's i that's true
that's one on one go one and one i think
now maybe as an adult i might like the
raisin hole but as a kid i hated it yeah
so don't be forced
i'll see somebody pick out raisins can i
have your raisins you're eating those
anyway you've have that with honey
apples with honey because that's round
roshan is great but families come over
you have lunch with another family yeah
but it's great meals and yom kippur the
10 days later that's just straight
repentance you don't wear leather or
anything
you [ __ ] tear your [ __ ] you tear your
like shirt and stuff
if it has a hole you don't sit in a high
tape chair no you just blow your bed
you're supposed to rip it just it's like
yeah it's like your morning so you know
no leather shoes can't wear leather it's
too nice
you don't say hello to anybody you just
nod
and that day that's when the the books
are closed so god keeps those judgment
books open
so if he's like you know what this guy's
being good
all right
better judgment but if he's not or
whatever he writes it in slams it shut
into the fact you can't eat from sundown
until sundown the next day 25 hour fast
no food no water
you would hate that part yeah and then
you have to go to a temple during it
which is even worse yeah and then you
finish and you just go both of you guys
grew up this way i i know well i do this
is the only like these holidays are like
christmas and easter so like my mom
would go for these
i mean do you take an objection with
what i said no i just remembering
something else i'm [ __ ] crazy go
ahead so yeah so these were like the big
ones so we would go
during these couple days and i hated it
because they're [ __ ] long like
shabbat would be like an hour but these
were like all like for four or five
hours and for like i would reform which
is basically a joke to him
so it's a joke yeah not even
conservative is like oh we fell apart a
little bit reforms like
let's redo it and you're like let's
[ __ ] make your own religion then
mormon
[ __ ] reformed
[ __ ]
and it is ridiculous make a new one they
have guitars
oh yeah they get up there and they sing
their songs and dance and i i don't mind
touch each other even though that's
[ __ ] you're not allowed clearly
and here's like the mom the women and
the men get separated sit separate
because well it's not their fault it's
our fault but we're all horn dogs
[ __ ] pray to god don't be sitting
there looking at the chick from your
class cross your legs
of course that's what you do that's a
good idea separate them
homosexuals throw a wrench in it
they should probably sit by themselves
but actually no because they're
attracted to themselves so sit alone
homosexuals have to get quarantined if
you really want to do it we can
concentrate on god they would have what
i would like to call the whole where if
you're gay you get thrown in there so
you can concentrate on god and not get
distracted by sex otherwise heterosexual
women you all sit together heterosexual
men you all sit together
bisexuals yeah you gotta go in the hole
for sure i don't see your way around
that men aren't even supposed to be
attracted to anybody like what is it
called like i saw and i forget it was
like these guys were walking with a
sheet so they could see but they
couldn't tell us you get the towels over
your head bruh yeah
so you can't even see them we used to
duck down to my dad who would like lift
up his like wing and get under there oh
my god it felt like the safest place in
the world
so anyway
they have to sacrifice something
in the old days you don't keep her rosh
hashanah i forget which one
and other ways you would offer a
sacrifice we did away with that we just
we pray they still do it yeah but so the
one time they do it is you say these
prayers
you
put your sins on a chicken
on the live chicken
you put your sins on them it's kind of
like confession and you like say these
prayers and you hold this chicken you
hold his head
and then when you finish that you hold
them by the neck and then you just start
spinning them around
you just start spinning
squawking and you just spin this [ __ ]
chicken spin it and spin it and spin it
and all your sins are on this [ __ ]
sin chicken
and you just spin it and you squawk it
and then you just stop squawking and you
just keep spinning it and then it's dead
you killed the [ __ ] sin chicken your
sins go with the chickens yeah let a
non-jew eat it yeah you let it can't eat
it let it eat it sell it off to one of
them i got this [ __ ] sin chick and
most of the sins don't count towards you
i was barely in israel but the one time
i was there i was there for yom kippur
and i would i was at in jerusalem the
night and the next day they had [ __ ]
chickens they were just all along the
alleyways of it's like tribesmen in
africa kind of behavior [ __ ] spin a
chicken over your head until it [ __ ]
dies
and they're chanting i'm in there in
some [ __ ] weirdo language and nobody
uses
they're [ __ ] nuts not you're not
spitting it the the
father spends
no not the rabbi my dad did it everybody
did it you get your chicken [ __ ]
killed the [ __ ] out of it when you're a
man sometimes what you can do is what
you probably did you put your sins on a
loaf of bread yeah you did that [ __ ]
yeah yeah we did that sometimes we went
and put in the river yeah then you take
the bread you throw it into the river
it's got your sins on it fish eat it now
they're the sinners it's a little it's a
little i mean that we did that a lot of
times we only did a sin chicken
sometimes we need to really some years i
don't know i think when mayweather
mayweather's like i'd do this chicken
four times a month but what just kill it
this way no it's different it's it's not
a sin chicken it's would you have
okay let's say
um
dressed up in weirdo [ __ ] with weird
belts with tassels on them they kill a
[ __ ] chicken and say
what you came uh
i'd say you came to me and you said you
know what jimmy i'm not feeling that
[ __ ] good lately
i go get a chicken
voodoo it it's santori ish i'm sorry
same [ __ ] difference but it's still
the same concept i grab it by the legs
i pick it up and i offer it to god and i
say ari sophia's here
he comes to offer you this you know take
care of his confusion take care of his
watch over and watch his path
then i take that chicken and you turn
counterclockwise
and i'm pretty much from your head i
wipe your shoulders with it your back
your arms your hands your feet and the
last thing is your hands yeah because
you want it to clean the [ __ ] from your
hands so you can get money
and then i take that chicken i chop its
[ __ ] neck off
i feed it to the saint the blood who's
the saints on the ground oh we take the
same town
what saint a statue of the sea that
saint that you wanna that you wanna pour
blood over a stained statue yeah like
it's not a statue but it's like a a
cauldron
with beach rocks in it and it says saint
anthony on it or something yeah like
it's an african name but it's still the
same concept oh you're cleaning your
sins it's still the same [ __ ]
you know you're losing you can't pick a
[ __ ] winner you come see me i get a
chicken i wipe your back i wipe your
neck i clean you down i kill the chicken
you [ __ ] uh
know somebody who just has some funky
[ __ ] on him
and it's getting into your head you come
to see me same type of concept
but really but not really you guys did
it once a year right let's see here yeah
yeah we get we did it whenever we felt
funky you picked four losers in my world
come on over let me kill a chicken for
you
do you see a santorie in new york ever
anymore no
i don't know what to even look for yeah
they're on the corners what do you mean
you walk by a corner and you see a
chicken in the bag or oh no i don't
couple broken eggs
that's santoria really yeah because it's
the same concept with the egg wow
if you uh
you work with somebody and they killed
somebody or they committed suicide
something like that
in santeria they want you to go home and
get an egg
and you cleanse yourself with the egg if
you don't have a chicken
you know what's that really yeah
i ate that uh those uh undeveloped eggs
when i was in cambodia what yeah what
undeveloped eggs it's got like a fetus
in there oh [ __ ] that yeah it's got like
a fetus it's foreign but it's all like
gelatinous
and they give it to you and then some
[ __ ] old men came by it's like that's
good for a night time it's supposed to
be this [ __ ] aphrodisiac or something
or boner pill i don't know i've seen
that at the andrew zimmern eat that on
travel time yeah eat that yeah it gets
presented to you and you i was like
all right let's go right now go do it
order it
yeah it was pretty gross but it tasted
fine did they have bones tasted fine
they put a little post like soy sauce in
it or some [ __ ] something like that
do they have what did they have bones in
it did it crunch no no it did not even
the beak was soft and there's like a
harder part so the eggs like that
there's like a hard part that's like
there
that's like all hard that you can't even
get through and the rest is all [ __ ]
up that's my birthday
that's my biggest fear of traveling what
food
really i don't like no one's gonna force
you to eat it no but what am i gonna be
[ __ ] eating on the road what is he
gonna instead he's gonna go [ __ ] eat
cockroaches what am i gonna eat [ __ ]
mcdonald's you gotta eat street food and
[ __ ] get sick where was this
that was in cambodia yeah i don't think
joey's going to cambodia but you could
go to like
japan that's why that's my favorite
that's the one i really want to go to
japan yeah
i think i'm gonna go there that seems
like fun
yeah
you could eat
the sushi yeah here it's but i'm sure
them they just chop the head off and
it's still swimming
and [ __ ] like that it's uh it's a
different experience the food i don't
know if it's china japan where you go
eat balls
did i have that in israel bulls balls in
a mixed grill and i'm like what is what
does kaduri mean because i thought i
knew i thought it meant balls cut door
saw cut or whatever and they're like
balls i'm like yeah but what does that
mean like here in terms of like
in the mixed grills it says kadarim like
yeah balls like what
they're like balls and i was like oh
yeah bulls testicles were they good
delicious what you know like why don't
they mix grill you get a bunch of stuff
little uh
liver chicken heart chicken heart maybe
um
balls
pieces of like beef
chopped you know onion [ __ ]
mixed grill now did you ever find good
chinese food in israel because i i was i
was duck sauce was red yeah that's there
it's like sweet and sour sauce yeah yeah
that is a [ __ ] up
but um they open up a pizza hut
they're near
jerusalem a mall
they had tuesdays all you could eat and
we would
eat an early dinner
on monday like 6 p.m and then not eat
anything until
four to five pm the next day and go in
and eat an entire pizza and then order
another pizza and eat one bite of that
go yeah i'm full wrap this up please
we would kill them
how was it i like it it's great it's
just pizza but you know but they have
like the when i was there they had like
corn on dominoes like that's some weird
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah that's like that
in every country they had sticky rice
they had brown sticky rice at burger
king really in chiang mai yeah
yeah
dude i had some questionable [ __ ] though
i had some oysters just in a like a you
know like a cooler but just like out in
vietnam down an alley and they were like
cooking them and i was like oh i mean
they looked great
but like
no freshness and it's just like
shelf just seafood just like shellfish
just open oysters or clams
out for a while and i was like yeah give
me an order of that
and then it's like let's let's see let's
take the ride that time i didn't get
sick
i can't do it guys i don't give a [ __ ]
you would never take like fresh oysters
i don't even like oysters here clams
they had [ __ ] on them i went to jamaica
one time and i just realized chickens on
the side of the road and [ __ ]
i went back to that hotel and that food
tasted so [ __ ] bad and those eggs
tasted weird to me the orange juice
tasted weird
i cannot do it i am too much of a
[ __ ] skeeve
i ski [ __ ] food too much but i
thought you'd love food my favorite
memory is one of you in san francisco
are going like i want some authentic
chinese telling that guy and he was okay
he goes nope but authentic and then he
took us to a good place and you were
like uh there's crawfish with eyeballs
in it you're like
a little too authentic a little too i
thought yeah yeah yeah
i need to pull it back a little bit
this dave foley took me to a place that
had some [ __ ] tremendous added
the potato pancakes but again i'm sold
on the east coast chinese food that's
what i grew up with the egg rolls the
best you can so
your [ __ ] mentality is
you be good chinese in new york you go
right to the village right you go right
to chinatown
yeah but honestly chinatown doesn't have
the best chinese same thing as little
italy hadn't nearly had the best yeah in
italian and it's not open the best only
wool hops open late
you would think they'd be open all hours
eleven you've got that like one choice
fine it's gross it's dirty it's dirty
it's not good food you have places in
the east village or like till 10 or 11
or like better you know szechuan food
georgie would always come torture me
about whoa
and i would tell you it's just it's just
the one that's open i i got chance till
11. i'm good
once i eat chan's i'm good i don't need
to go into the village to let my friends
know i went to a village see chinese but
you're already in new jersey
yeah what time is last call in new york
they don't know what you're talking
about that's business by business
whenever they want
it's not at all is it four or is it
three no it's not though well i was
gonna try until the story has come up
i've been in bars and seen through the
cracks where i'm like oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] sunlight
how crazy they just don't kick you out
how crazy is that you're in a bar and
you walk out and you need sunglasses
it's crazy but it's so it feels so cool
so cool you're like i stayed up all
night you see it's the the air is like
clean
especially if it's like six instead of
like nine or ten nine or ten people
already out but if you get out like six
it's like still kind of quiet and you're
like oh yeah you feel like [ __ ]
accomplished something i pulled my first
coke all night when i was about 17 with
didi quintero
but to go into a bar
at two in the morning
and do blow and drink beer and walk out
of that bar at 7 30 in the morning
when the sun's out yeah you have this
weirdest feeling the first couple times
you do it you think you're [ __ ]
sinatra yeah i feel like you really do
the first three to four times that you
stay out all night with your friends
and you walk out at seven and you're
like where are we gonna go eat or maybe
you can't even eat because you're so
[ __ ] coked up
you you feel like look at me yeah i'm
getting places and you wake up the next
thing you tell everybody dog we stayed
out all night where the [ __ ] were you it
was a blast there was no blast it was
five guys on one broad looking at the
same broad to all [ __ ]
and a bartender with a glass eye and
everybody's looking at this one chick
you know to [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of all
coked up and at the end of the night you
don't go home with nobody
five guys gotta go home and bang it out
on their own
like [ __ ] like that like we'd leave a
bar at seven but then there was a club
in the city i would go to an 83-84
they would give me sunglasses on the way
out
really they would give you like three
dollar sunglasses oh really so you could
go home in peace
[Laughter]
i couldn't even imagine
yeah me and mark norman sometimes stay
up pulling all-nighters anymore like i
couldn't sometimes just hanging out
talking for a while what the what's the
difference like going to a bar and just
bellying up and drinking bud lights with
a bag of potato chips
all those bars in new york you have
potato chips sometimes there's pizza in
there in the room or you can order pizza
to brooklyn you can order pizza to a bar
and just be like yeah and then you just
eat it there
you've gotten pizza delivered to them
i've seen it a bunch of times yeah
people could do well holy [ __ ] they
don't care we don't sell food yeah get
up get a pizza
yeah it's so [ __ ] cool in those back
portion patios in like brooklyn god damn
like when you're in l.a if you get coked
up till four in the morning
yeah you're driving home on sunset at
four there's not a car out it's peaceful
it's peaceful like you're like what the
[ __ ] am i doing
what is wrong with my life but in new
york
you walk out of a [ __ ] club and
you're high and the sun's out you're
like look at me dawg this is rolling
stones type [ __ ] yeah you feel like john
lennon staying out of a [ __ ] night
yeah then after a while you just become
a loser right it's like come on
every night stop it
it's it's funny man i listen to this
thing
and you guys might not like it but i
listen to it for the stupidity and i
gotta tell you something i listen to it
every sunday
i usually take a ride while it's on and
i know if i'm gonna light the people on
the show within the first seven minutes
yeah but you catch good people on that
and i listened to studio 54 radio
on serious radio and on sunday night
some lady who was the
the uh
what is that [ __ ] the kojak
no you know what i'm talking about the
lady who does the appointments yeah the
vip list
she is the host of the show
she was the official lady who made the
vip list for studio 54 oh really night
and what she hosts this show called
studio 54
and two people go in there and talk
about their life
when they were going to studio 54.
like she knew him
like this week they had a [ __ ]
tremendous woman
who hung out with andy wall and just
said that he ran with 16 deep
and how
in new york andy warhol didn't do drugs
so still 54 of those nights andy wall
didn't do drugs but in the daytime he
would go to milkshake bars in the
village that's where men went to meet
with men
they went and had milkshakes
milkshake bars and if you knew the
bartender he put gin in there for you
really have a vodka or whatever he
wanted milkshake but they just talked
about their lifestyles ari who these
people talk about their lifestyles at
that time
how they were living oh yeah like the
best one i ever heard oh these are the
interviews like the interviews
it's like a podcast yeah but of people
who
like it's like us when we're 60 yeah and
they call us and they go do me a favor
talk about the store from night from
2000 to 2005. yeah and we're still
talking about mitzi and yeah you know
this guy worked the door and there was
this other guy that worked the door was
missing a foot and you were [ __ ] the
chick upstairs and i had that chick with
the dirty fingernails that would suck my
dick for a spot
you know this is what's going to happen
30 years from now when you're sitting
there in your bed thinking your life is
over some young 28 year old kid's going
to call you guys raise your feet high my
name is john smith no no no don't hang
up
what do you want he's going to listen
we are part of this new radio station
called the comedy store the wonder years
and we love the wonder years
i would love for you to call in and
discuss your relationship with joey diaz
rest in peace and joe rogan rest in
peace you're the only one that's left
from that crew
can you call in tomorrow night and tell
us about your life in times
at the comedy store from 2000 to 2010
all right this is the first time
somebody's called you in three years all
right i'm saying yeah
what aren't you gonna tell that guy yeah
i tell them you're gonna go listen can i
fly myself to you
it's gonna be a while yeah
these are people that probably are
studio 54 was in the 70s how they had
stories so this is 50 [ __ ] years ago
so these people are in their 70s so they
come on this show but about the first
time i ever heard this was like on a
sunday night i needed weed and i got in
the car at 6 30 we just had dinner and i
had studio 54 radio on and i caught this
husband team talking about their life
they were jewish
nice jewish couple and they were talking
about how their kids were growing up but
let me let me tell you our lifestyle
what it was in 1975 and then he goes
shoot
and he goes number one
for years liza minnelli thought we were
like real estate agents they didn't know
that we were dentists
so this husband and wife team
was a were two dentists yeah and they
had somebody else who worked the office
they lived in the brownstone and their
mother lived downstairs the mot the
wife's mother lived downstairs
so this was their itinerary they would
get home from studio 54
at six in the morning have breakfast
with the kids
and then one of them would take the kids
to school and they'd sleep till 11
and they'd get up at 11 get ready go to
work from 12 to four go home pick up the
kids cook dinner
they would have to help the kids with
homework take a nap till 11
and then go to studio 54.
five nights a week wow and the lady was
like i remember those days you guys were
there the people were like tuesday
through saturday
we were at studio 54
until six in the morning and they
started talking about who they saw there
and they're talking about how they
tied up bob hope one night what bob hope
went in there one night and they the
owner of the studio 54 said go get him
and a bunch of hot chicks went around
bob hope and started tying them up with
toilet paper at the left of the toilet
paper they brought out a rope and [ __ ]
and that bob hope was turning red they
just started telling stories are you
about
john f you know not that the one kennedy
and how paul castellano went like
everybody at one time had to go to
studio 54 to see what the [ __ ] was going
on
and it's just interesting that those
people live like that like when i read
the lenny bruce book
before i got into comedy that
[ __ ] did comedy till five
during the week at jazz and strip clubs
and then he would go home and shoot
heroin at the chelsea hotel and he would
get up about one or two and go eat
breakfast that's the life i wanted like
that's it that getting home at six every
night and picking up a daily news and a
fresh-squeezed orange juice taking it
upstairs turning on the news
a little salute smoke a joint and pass
out like by [ __ ] 7 30. i loved all
that [ __ ]
i loved working nights that was my world
i dreamt of that [ __ ]
walking in while you're walking out
i always loved that idea i'm walking in
while all you humps are walking out
you lumps are going to work i'm going to
sleep i loved working nights that's why
i always knew
that i had to do something at night i
hated the day jobs all right i [ __ ]
knew
listen everybody who the [ __ ] wants to
work during the [ __ ] daytime i like
the idea of being a mason and working
construction an electrician
but suck my dick
i wanted to work [ __ ] night so i can
have the days to myself
it's so weird because my mom had that
type of [ __ ] she worked nights she
worked nights in her body she was able
to go to baseball games no at her bar
yeah so she was able to go to baseball
games she was able to go to a racetrack
at one o'clock you're still able to
enjoy the day is what my point is
oh yeah how come i haven't really heard
of another bar like studio 54. that's
like really like the only famous
club like that is there are there other
ones or do i just not go to class after
that time in new york city they they had
like area
and they had the one that's the church
that's still there
on the 20th and west side it's a church
but now it used to be a church they
turned it into a club and they had all
these spots lately i was not a club guy
i would go like if ari would call me and
go joey
come with me tonight test or whatever i
got like an eight ball of blow let's
take a ride over and i'll eat some
quaaludes
i went to studio one time and it was not
when mick jagger was hanging out there
it had to be like 84 on a thursday night
like a friend of mine took me i used to
go to a place to rooftop because it was
a cocaine place all those places
were basically cocaine places you're
looking at me like what's a cocaine
place yeah that me you and lee could pay
12 bucks that it was like all you can
snort no it was no [ __ ]
it was a rooftop it was 17 if you walked
in at 11
and it was 12 if you walked in after
four
but it was all you could drink
all right so you me and lee would sit
down seventeen dollars yeah you just
1983 the drink back then
whatever it was all you could drink so
it's watered down alcohol but you didn't
give a [ __ ] by the time you walked in
there you dropped a loot or a tumen all
right and you had a half eight ball in
here and you had 30 cocktails somewhere
else you just went in there to continue
the party and be able to drink yeah so
what you did was you went in there in
those days in 1983 if you got an 8-ball
and i had an 8-ball it went on the table
really yeah in front of 200 people
and we would be having our own
conversation snorting talking about
baseball you got yours i got mine
yeah we'd be all doing it together here
try this do this do this you need a
pillow yeah boom that's what you're paid
for
in the mid-80s until about 1990 when you
went to those clubs that's what you paid
for to be able to go to a bathroom and
snort you know in studio like in most
clubs that you went to
all the bathrooms are like the main room
bathroom yeah with those chairs with the
mirror in front of it with the light
over it
and you could go into the woman's
bathroom at those discos sit down and
snorkel
and women would go pee
and they didn't say nothing to you all
right as long as you didn't [ __ ] with
them while they were peeing whatever
you're using them for yeah there's not
coke in there like every place in the
club was
how much how much is an eight ball at
that time yeah like no no no no
no how much does it cost how how much
coke do you get three and a half grams
show me on the back let's just say that
was full of coke how much how much would
that three and a half grams is
not the weight of it but the look of it
you know like let's say it was all coke
what that down there
yeah
that's it wow wait wait he's getting us
some more exact amount let me see
that let me see i'm gonna say and this
might be like five grams oh so maybe
even less than that even less than that
how many lines you get out of that how
many lines you have an eight ball it
depends how big you make the lines you
know
little tiny things like this
i should get from that you should get
eight grams out of a half gram eight
snorts out of a half gram yeah eight
snorts out of half gram yeah oh so there
you go that's a long time though yeah
and that's it's it's an eighth yes so
three and a half grams
oh so if you get eight at a half a gram
yeah because your lines
okay your lines are going to be like
this okay
when i say
lines for half gram
56 56 snorts you get 56 snorts out of
that that's that's a lot that's a long
night right i don't know how many snores
do you need three
oh
that was so wet that's what you need cox
that was so wet that's tremendous that's
the protein powder all right this is a
line you're showing me a line this is a
line i'm talking about
you could get eight lines like this oh
this is perfect knowledge
eight lines like that so that's one two
a little thicker
okay so i got five there but i take a
little piece off each one here oh i need
to take a little piece off
am i getting text
and i got six there see all right and
then clean it up a little bit you take
that one
and i'm saying oh wow yeah i could see
so lines like this yeah how long does
that get you high for if you do one of
those lines i would have to do three of
these to get the party started okay wait
about 10-15 minutes and bang out the
other three wow we'd be talking [ __ ]
here for how long
an hour and a half an hour and a half
that would get you going with alcohol
yeah
you don't even need this much with
alcohol
but really it's that alone
get it started then get back to an hour
and a half after that you're like good
and high yeah okay that's nice that's a
nice long time [ __ ] up all night and
how much would one of those be those
eight balls back then
back then it was probably uh 250 to 300.
oh
now it's one and a quarter it's less
because it's not even cocaine anymore no
it's cocaine it's just we're we're
fueled with it's everywhere
so it's over saturated oversaturated
that's what i mean too easy to get yeah
like you know
it's uh it that's what they do they
flood the streets with it and the more
of it you know now
remember you have oxycontin to compete
with yeah and you also have regular aids
to compete with oh yeah so the problem
there is that [ __ ] uh
there's a lot of competition
it's not just
you can't sell in 84
when all that all that [ __ ] you guys are
watching on narcos yeah they're talking
about that [ __ ] now now it moved into
like 87 88
but when we first watched the second
season of narcos
even this season they said something
very interesting remember when they
couldn't get the ether right yeah
absolutely in the 80s there was a part
like 85 86 where your coke started
tasting funky
and it was because they couldn't get
ether and smuggled into colombia anymore
they needed ether to wash it we were
talking about this last week they were
washing out gasoline and
and paint solvent and [ __ ] so your coat
tastes [ __ ] up
that was the big issue because they
couldn't get any ether then they sent
troops down there like 85 86
and that made them move that made them
go to cuba and process it it skyrocketed
cocaine skyrocketed by only six man
cocaine there were some people that were
getting eighteen hundred to two thousand
an hour wow and they would put a little
tiny bit of cut of it they saved it so
you paid top dollar and you knew you
were getting top quality what you did
with it was your business so on coke
that cost 1800 a guy like you could
throw
10 grams on it
and now you started with 28 now you got
38.
if you keep three for yourself and sell
35 grams 100 hours a piece
you doubled your money
a slick little hustle like yourself
you don't
grind up the coke you leave some coke
rocks and you just chunk up the other
rest and mix it with the cut
so you're basically mixing maybe
15 with 10. yeah you keep the other
rocks out so the customer sees the rock
and that's what gets their dick card you
gotta hang on all day long
i don't even know why we're talking
about this [ __ ] you know who's thinking
of becoming a drug dealer here nobody
wants this drug deal 101 this afternoon
what the [ __ ] here it's expensive like
like people complain about like the
price of like
at the dispensaries they're like oh
that's expensive for a gram but a
hundred bucks a hundred and twenty five
dollars for three and a half grams of
cocaine is a [ __ ] gift really yeah oh
i know people give you half eight for 65
bucks that's a gram and three-quarters
that's perfect so you're you're really
good at the metric system huh who you
i have no idea what what and i figured
it out i figured you figured see 20 30
years ago they were telling you in the
school system already
that in 10 years there was not going to
be no more inch or gallons it was all
going to go to metric you remember that
that was the fear they were telling us
that that it was going to they were
threatened they tried that yeah so when
cocaine came along in the 80s like oh
here it is it's changing
it's changing with drugs
quarter ounces eights
half ounces half pounds
remember when you bought fireworks they
taught you how to remember what's a lot
that's a lot yeah 100 oh a lot of them
yeah no no a lot is like 124 like a mac
12x12 yeah something like that 12 144
yeah 144 packs
it was crazy when you bought like
firecrackers that's how you learn to do
[ __ ] math
all right quickly on the run on the run
[ __ ] as a criminal sure that's how i
did my best [ __ ] math you gotta do
math quick in your [ __ ] head
you call me up you you corner me in a
[ __ ] bar on a friday night
and you're all coked up and you give me
an ear beat and ari's the coke dealer
but you don't know that
you corner me at the bar
if [ __ ] larry opens his mouth harry
will stab him because you're my
commission
you're following me
not really so if you come into our
corner me and aria over here are counted
up right talking about devils and [ __ ]
and you looking for me and you're like i
got some [ __ ] arie's not gonna raise his
head
because i'm your [ __ ] man so i'm
gonna come you over tell you to give me
a hundred let me call the guy give me 10
minutes go to your car and wait the
guy's right here
all right yeah the guy's right in front
of me i'm just going to tell you to go
wait outside so i could take something
out of the bag
[Laughter]
that's your profit that's your [ __ ]
cut for bothering me [ __ ]
but i'll never let him give it to you
because the next time he gives it to you
you're going to say jesus christ
every time i get it from joey i got a
light package
every time i get it from you i get the
full [ __ ] amount here
what's the amount of dog that bong had
hit you oh yeah my mind's gone
wandering
this weed is tremendous dog yeah this is
we ain't [ __ ] already at the church
why the church of when church of [ __ ]
death do you want to stop
one of these 125 hours 120. i don't want
you get half of it it's it's [ __ ]
tuesday night when you're doing your
life
what the [ __ ] are you gonna do with your
life
it's an excuse for every day of the week
by the way tuesday it's the lord it's
the lord's brother's day tuesday night
half a star we'll get out of here we'll
go to mornings and get a steak some
[ __ ] i can get some food i definitely
want to get some food at some point yeah
there's a taco place down in the corner
and there's a [ __ ] jersey mike about
a thousand dollars you're going to end
up at that taco place oh please and
you're going to be there too [ __ ]
yeah but he said morton's you always try
to you always try to get us with a good
one first we'll call them but look at
the shape of us
three [ __ ]
pieces of death in there and [ __ ] oh i
did when you were when you gave us that
gift card last christmas we went i went
in there at lunch time high as [ __ ] i
was laughing in the in the waitress's
face yourself no paulo was there but i
was the only one hi
sure we only had one three of them today
i said this is light day
like this look like larry
yeah that's two it's not together i
don't even care
you don't even care
you guys just like the gummy yeah we
ain't got time to care i'm just hoping
there's no horse i love these people who
do all this [ __ ] investigative
reporting before they either
they drive me crazy
the webmd what the [ __ ] just eat the
things
but he's half of it he don't eat the
whole thing
it's tuesday night you don't want to get
that [ __ ] up you just want to get some
appetite so those tacos taste good
yeah oh my god
yeah that's more than i normally take
how much do you normally take
30 milligrams that's perfect really
35. you you doing a spot to start
tonight right no i'll go i'm doing my
show tomorrow okay
um
i don't know i can't believe we get high
off 30 milligrams
yeah
that was what half those breath ships
used to be it was 25 milligrams
breast ships were 50 right each one was
50. no [ __ ] no
they just tried to make a comeback but
each one was 100 no so 50 milligrams is
what i take okay 50 milligrams is my
thing that's still blood 30 i'm already
risking i'm not getting high but then
sometimes now i can get high off that
it's 50. 50 is my life
ha those breast chips were 100 back then
half them were 50 that was like the
dosage they get to get [ __ ] up though
and by the way joey diaz also got [ __ ]
up back then off the same amounts i know
but i see the but the bread shirt used
to stick together
everybody said put them in your wallet
when you travel you put them in your
wallet there was three to a package
there was two to a pack there was only
ever always two to a pack so sometimes i
think it was either two or three it was
for sure no no no no no no no no never
stopping two it always started the two
it's it was three and two of them got
stuck together you gotta you got a
[ __ ] four leaf clover one time and
you thought that's the way they were oh
it's two it's always been two do you
wanna just also bought in like eight
packs at a time oh raptor would send me
in there he's like get however much this
try to give me a deal as much as this is
the [ __ ] whole thing started the best
edibles were coming out of [ __ ]
kushmart
cushmart had a gummy bear yeah that was
purple that came in a baggie that the
baggie had like hash roll in it oh like
if it cracked your fingers were slippery
for a week like transmission fluid oh it
was worse just so like they didn't know
what they were doing
and i'll never forget eating one of
those things and tripping on a flight to
pittsburgh
and then they had a brownie that was 100
milligrams but they didn't really know
they were just killing people they were
a little bodega on [ __ ]
off of hollywood oh my god like not even
on the main street they weren't even
kawenga years later they went to kawenga
they were the size of this lee
really that was kushmart i went to you
took me by gower when i first went to
cushman it was on gower off of hollywood
boulevard and those little huts they
just tore down on the way to sunset by
your [ __ ] favorite chickens plot
roscoe's right roscoe's you went to yeah
go north towards hollywood on the right
hand side gotcha that's what cushmar was
the little side
little they used to have acting studios
in there i had an acting teaching that
had to have and he was dying but he
would do his knowledge but he would do
midnight thought he would meet me at 11
and coach me for 25 hours really and
doug i want i got some [ __ ] call
backs with that dude from big movies he
knew what he was doing nice he
disappeared what happened what do you
think i've been doing with his aides
do you think he's okay today no he's
playing the piano at the
intercontinental hotel on tuesday i've
always been here
yeah that was where the original cushmar
was then they moved to a side street by
where
near yucca and [ __ ] yeah
they were right there they were there
then they got [ __ ] greedy and they
bought the building on the corner oh
yeah they bought the downstairs for the
doctor for the doctor and upstairs for
the weed swept oh you don't have your
apartment well go get it right now go
get it done you'll be in a ladder today
they had it going on man we've just
changed when you go through hollywood
now you're like what the [ __ ] are all
these billboards billboards for weird
what we maps is everywhere
yeah weed maps is everywhere but it's
also like
it's like fine so it's around so it's
just a business now so just [ __ ] you
know have it around
it's just but you know what
they've thrown it in your face now yeah
it's like john gotti and [ __ ] 85
they're throwing it right in your face
so eventually my fear is that the the
sanctuary state and trump's going to
[ __ ] bust our balls oh yeah that'd be
awful that's defeated my fear is if it
gets so over in your face that people
just taste goes and it's gross [ __ ]
stop and they come down the pendulum
swings because of that because they're
chewing the [ __ ]
too much well look what's happened to
marijuana now
it's like those vapes what ten years ago
i [ __ ] took my credit card and i
spent five thousand dollars one month
at that weed store on santa monica we
used to go to yeah close to that uh
was it by this comedy store well there
was that one but then there was another
one close to the
fairfax and santa monica down there the
original oh yeah yeah but they got way
overpriced yes they were fantastic the
pharmacy yeah they were like what and
you tried their 70.8 like what are you
kidding me like it's great and you try
like it's not it's like 50 races 50 west
hollywood prices you're charging 70
for 60 i want something to kill me
for 70 i've only
had that be worth it like once or twice
i was walking out of there with 280.
third eye was only 50. 280 a day
what are you talking about how is that
even possible 315 a day what how much
money you would put into it he said 5
000 a month 5 000 a month my wife made
me pay and then she took the card from
me
i was buying the ice cream
the chocolate remember they had
everything that's the laura's other
stuff this was way beforehand this one
that still was like it was like okay
this was the [ __ ] banana bread days
how much was it incredible though before
that possibly way leash unknown unknown
unknown it was cake
it was these are pretty strong it was
cake it was edibles and then they had a
particular cookie for 15 bucks that lee
would kill you so how are you spending
no 100 no no no your place lit me and
nick yousef up once took a little hash
cupcake just like that in one of those
little tins you know for like parmesan
cheese and [ __ ]
just that that that's how full it was
and we ate it went to [ __ ] clash of
titans and both of us just on our own
just walked away from the movie
he caught me out there staring at a
[ __ ]
somebody's name and hand prince
peanut butter
at the place that moved by schrader
what was that place called the one you
took me to
the the cushmore cushmark yeah everyone
you got cushmark and walk to man's
chinese no they didn't have they didn't
really know what was going on it was
like what they really didn't know about
edibles and delicious but they're like
these are hash
hashtags yeah they were putting ash they
used to have these hash cookies leave
three cookies for 10 bucks listen to me
i was 418 pounds
i couldn't walk [ __ ] two minutes on
the treadmill
and i was walking so he decided to eat
more cake no i would go there
i went to weight watchers and i would go
to that treadmill at night and i would
walk
the weight on my knees was so bad i
didn't know what to do i didn't know
about ice on my knees then i didn't know
nothing
and one day i went to cushman i'm
talking to the girl she goes why are you
limping like i'm exercising the bicycle
she goes eat those hash cookies a bunch
of old people been coming in here and
getting those hash cookies they'll put
you on a different planet it was three
cookies for 10 bucks at least lee
if you ate all three cookies
jesus christ before you work out
no i would do it when i get home okay
that was the first edible that made me
gummy
there was two edibles that i was suspect
about that one and the cookies from the
pharmacy and years later somebody told
me that the cookies from the pharmacy
were putting xanax in them
that's why you were getting so [ __ ] up
oh wow
they put xanax in the pharmacy cookies
yeah this is yeah what
this is 15 years ago what
something every time you ate that cookie
from the pharmacy the house specialty
cookie
you
because people want to say like it
always puts me out it's like oh perfect
yeah these are the cookies cookies all
natural then from the then from the
pharmacy you and i [ __ ] around with
the black chick by dukes
down there town sunset yes yeah the
black how cute chick from the bronx from
yeah
oh yeah no no she was the brothers yeah
they all went over to the zen oh right
right and they all went over to zen yeah
she was cool she was beautiful she was
gracious her eyes were always red she
would always be stoned to the gift oh
yeah it's like it's like i was always
saying it's like hey what are you on
right what do you want right there
that's what i used to tell you look she
looks so happy yeah you taught me that
she used to have beautiful nails
and she would tap on the glass the weeds
she'd have you go like what are you
smoking and she'd go right here baby
that's remember they used to have weed
and vending machines yeah they were the
joints and the grams were in the venus
this had to be it's not worth that time
they're over there
this high school eighths are better 2003
and they weren't dry they were good
there is and those places were the
vending machines the nose no the stuff
on the other board those stuff in the
vending machines was great oh no they
replaced every day they go through it
every day every day i used to i used to
i was getting lee i was getting huge i
was eating a chocolate bar every day
well yeah and in those days they didn't
pay the milligrams but the chocolate was
dull they didn't tell you the calories
either were you sharing it or something
like how could you get through talking
to you oh [ __ ] you sharing it
i would give up
something oh so you were there no an
eight would be
from there would be 90. an eighth would
be 90. 90 to 100. so that includes
regular weed okay do you remember why
you like that place
there was a russian place across the
street from rouse with the hot looking
natasha yeah yeah yeah the russian
chubby girl they let you in one at a
time
cage yeah that place was great they had
the anti-dolores stuff first they had
the other guy stuff first both those
brands were great
and they also had obama 10 years ago
they had on sale prices they had 30
dollars a gram for obama yeah back then
they had the on sale prices were like
wednesday if you come in wednesday you
get like everything half or whatever you
know where they are now where sunset
herbal
up the corner they're not still there no
they closed up they were the same oldest
i want to get the peanuts the peanuts
the coated stuff you just eat them in
front of people no one know what you
were doing and then lee after that we
went to i used to go to a place by
justin fortune's gym it's still there if
you go to uh sierra bonita and sunset
there's like a coffee shop but there's a
head shop
it's down the corner from 7-eleven on
curson it has been there since you moved
here sorry
really you have been in there to get
papers at one time or another it's close
to el compadre a block and a half up
from elk and padre yeah they have a back
room
and the kid was a chef at that
real popular restaurant on
robertson
and [ __ ] like
wilshire or
santa monica back when we moved here
and something happened he started
messing around with edibles
so he quit his chef job and he talked
himself and that guy pete it was big
pete he weighed like 600 pounds yeah
mmp'd opened up a weed store they had
the girl that
they just did a show on
real tv about a vietnamese girl that was
growing grenade weed that was that broad
he was getting the weed from her she had
a strain of weed that was tremendous
remember we shot those episodes did you
ever shoot those episodes of the weed
store with me and edward san juan and
felipe no it was at that weed place but
really to make a long story that was
happening on [ __ ] tuesdays
he would make fresh edibles every week
he was a chef
and he had devised a way to put make
like
italian ice animals he made like uh
cream to brulee out of bulls really yeah
he was the first he was [ __ ] knocking
it out of the park
and that's when i used to go down there
at 11 he'd give me like 50 worth of
stuff for 10 bucks i'd eat it because i
was such a gavon
and i would go to acupuncture in those
days 11 45 every tuesday and pass out
because i'd be so high from the edibles
as soon as she put a needle in me i just
[ __ ] pass that really
that was a great place and then once
they went under
where like uh
cushmart i stayed at cushmar for years
yeah krishna wasn't bad and then once i
moved to the valley like the russians
are like kushmart i like zen a lot they
were like my hometown they were pricey
but they never had anything bad and then
hit you with deals sometimes they're
like what's like you taught me how to do
it i'd be like what's what's killing
people these days and they'd be like
actually this [ __ ] 45
we like juicy fruit one time he was like
he's getting great reports like all
right give me any of that
and it was so good
sometimes you gotta talk like this place
up here
the russians they had a girl that looked
like a runaway yeah and i'll bet you any
amount of money this girl was a runaway
she wasn't good looking but she was very
sweet
and every time i went in there all the
other girls were hi you don't hold on i
gotta wait for her
for months i would just go to go do me a
favor
give me the best weed and she would come
with some weed that looked kind of weird
but i'd take it home and go whoa
and she just had a nose for it most
girls that tolerance is [ __ ] yeah so you
go in there you go in there they tell
you this is the best stuff and you bring
it home you're like this doesn't do
nothing to me well the girl weighs 90
pounds she does a hit of the worst [ __ ]
on the [ __ ]
shelf she'll get high
but some of those girls are
professionals you just got to pick them
out like that little runaway chick that
[ __ ] was a reef of professional jack
i would go in there and she'd go hold on
i got something for you and sometimes it
looked a little questionable but i never
said a word i always bought an eighth
and sure enough the next day
and you have those you find if you go to
the same weed store yeah and you build a
relationship with them and they watch
you like years ago oh you'd like this
con you always like that yes
this does sort of the same thing but
yeah the best weed from cushma what they
were known for was mats og the mats
number one number one oh gee that's what
they were known for yeah if you smoked
that all the time your tolerance is
going to be up there
those are the ones matt's number one rgb
one third eye and third eye third eye
was like that's what everything else was
ninety dollars
third eye was fifty
and third eye the first time i bought a
bag of third oh
i didn't know what was going on i
couldn't breathe
you know there's just certain brands
that come along to these weed stops
these wheat stores that they buy eight
pounds of and they don't know the guy
they the guy came in and you know what
he undersold them on it it was a shitty
price you know the guy just wanted to
bail but the wii turns out to be superb
yeah wait of the year i don't judge a
lot of people
still asking for that third eye he still
talks about the [ __ ] trip he had on
that no no no that we was trying to
never came back again my fa it didn't
and the favorite was like people
actually like is it sativa or indica and
you you were like yeah it'll get you to
all those places
like it's not even like that it'll take
you everywhere
listen man yeah you don't know that
third eye was so good
i like it and the match matches around
more the hybrids have to have a dominant
uh dominant whatever
uh the indica has to be the the hybrids
have to be indica dominant for me to
really enjoy them
sativas they're sativas that i smoke and
nothing happens but they're sativas that
i smoke
and they get me higher than the indicas
i just have to hunt them out
and sometimes it's by smell it used to
be new york diesel
new york sour diesel okay that sour
diesel when people had it in abundance
but then people started renaming it and
i lost
the original strength yeah i just bought
sour diesel in a couple weeks so i gave
it to somebody i like sativas if you
love certain strands i'm not that into
sour diesels like why not i never like
sour days all that much this i like
headband
i like maui wowie a lot like why didn't
you buy matzo g seeds like why didn't
you do something like that why don't you
buy food
does he look like johnny gordia he could
if i strike an image in your head johnny
grower right
you picture that guy yes you know what
he does what his like houses looks like
johnny grower yeah okay you ready right
open your eyes and look at joey diaz you
tell me does that look like that [ __ ]
johnny grow with you he's like johnny
overseer what's the what's like what's
the boss let me explain something to you
leave first off he's not johnny grower
when you grow when you grow marijuana
that's a full-time thing experimental
times you gotta get somebody who knows
it's a lot of effort cost money i'm not
gonna just keep keep it in your freezer
for an old different or you can just be
like
oh okay you mean to buy a lot
what are you saying well no just to like
just to keep it you mean grow it get
seeds and [ __ ] grow it yourself
at a later date maybe not then but just
like knowing what you know now no no i
don't i still wouldn't [ __ ] grow it i
look like johnny grow it to you i've
heard people i would have put someone in
touch with a grower and be like you
can't get that seed too you can grow the
seed and give me a percentage of it yeah
like i've heard you guys talk about
i got some afghani seeds like you want
to grab but i don't have time to [ __ ]
let you know this weed is like the ring
of gondor how many times i sprinkle
seeds on dust and then a year later i
came by and there was pop plants but
there was nothing there's no buds
there was nothing it's just like i don't
know what the [ __ ] i'm doing you got to
put hydrogen in there and
feed the stuff and what the [ __ ] i got
time at 54 to learn a whole new thing
i'm going to learn something from the
guitar
and you're not going to do that
that was taking a month
learn to play the guitar thinking about
it you should do it
you know what man i really enjoy going
to jiu jitsu and writing right now i
really like right yeah but maybe after
jiu jitsu class you tell all the guys
like hey guys sit around i'll play a
song for you guys [ __ ] that you had a
nice tough time working out take a load
off [ __ ] that take a load off
your [ __ ] play for them right there
you want to play the [ __ ]
no
you could do it once you finish the book
no no no no no no no no hey guys you
know me as joey diaz but today um johnny
ukulele hit it and then maybe get
somebody else who plays like he's a sexy
ukulele player he holds his own
yeah he's there he's in the picture
people have to talk about i'm gonna talk
about who the [ __ ] oh my goodness
that's hysterical like the sports heroes
was a badminton player there was jack
purcell was a was a top level badminton
player
i did not know i mean i know that guy's
name
how big did you have to get as a
badminton player that i know your name
50 years later
i don't think they still make jack
bracelets they dude maybe jack parcells
for sure i've seen him
nobody knows who the [ __ ] jackpot i
didn't know who he was yeah but i know
i've seen the shoe i didn't know what
that meant
for sure
i want to buy another pair of chucks
right now
i think they wouldn't i haven't had
trucks in years really but i don't think
they would work out for me now
no comfort
yeah no put a [ __ ] thing in there
uh
new balance sells one of those companies
sells a great [ __ ] thing for your
shoes i had them i gotta get a new pair
of those that's all i wear if i walk now
i gotta wear new balance if i [ __ ]
dress
on stage i gotta wear my adidas but i
gotta taste i might do two shows
my [ __ ] achilles tendon hurts the
next morning my bursitis starts coming
back sure miss pat said about
charlottesville what she goes relax
white people nobody's trying to replace
you
who else would buy a new balance
we have wide feet i can't help it i
don't know yeah we have white feet
i don't get that because no black people
buy new balance
well that's right yeah i just got that
well
see i'm so happy we [ __ ] and smoked
some reef elisa always happy so what are
we doing tomorrow night we're doing
shows a show about what
schools schools and what's the name of
this show
um
um
uh back to school aria shaffer's renamed
storytelling show but no you're not
supposed to tell anybody the lineup's a
surprise
who gives a [ __ ] that's fine i want a
surprise i'll wait on [ __ ] 12 again
okay fair enough [ __ ] wrong with your
surprise
what are we talking about schools
what are you talking about
think about what this is going to come
out before i do the thing
when are you going to put this out
whatever you want tomorrow afternoon
when are you planning this out well
whatever well then do it afterwards sure
whatever
i didn't just do it after wednesday or
wednesday night put it on wednesday at
eight you're fine yeah it won't be fun
i'm gonna probably talk about like
doing i was in school not lying for like
a while trying to not lie for a week
see if i could do it i had these dumb
challenges i would do for myself when
you were in school yeah grammar school
high school college college yeah
let's see if i couldn't lie for a week
now you're a terrapin yeah all four
years nope first year yeshiva university
yeshivas
yeah and then you transfer this did i
try i lost my religion boom gotta go
there's a waste of money now let's go to
state school
you lost your religion yeah like rem
like hurry up yeah yeah
when you lost your religion what did
your parents say to you not happy about
it
not happy about it is that that scene in
rounders
what when he told him he was gonna be a
gambler
when he told him
he needed the money and he gave the
money and he goes before you give me the
money
let me tell you a story i went through
yeshiva but i didn't want to do it
oh yeah
you forgot about that they forgot about
that see if they got it online rounders
uh what was that he just died that actor
he just martin landau
who the [ __ ]
do you think you're dealing with
i used to i was a fan of mountain land
down since i was a kid it was a mission
impossible so what's the rounders and
what's up rounders
martin landau and what's his [ __ ]
name
what's the guy's name in that movie matt
damon forget that of course
well [ __ ] you people think that i don't
know what i'm doing here i know
i know lines from movies different
situations
while lee finds it let me [ __ ] give
you uh that one destiny chooses us
destiny chooses as well real real quick
let me give you a quick shout out quick
shout outs ricky bobby andrew joseph
okay
chango bus 26 mike rayback
trill chico
14 jamie foxton chris tent and my man
jacob rogers you know your uncle joey
loves you [ __ ] you never saw this
lee
ah no i haven't this is what i'm talking
about
turn it up and press play you got it
by my love of
christ the pride of my yeshiva
the elders said i had a 40 year old's
understanding of the midrash by the time
i was 12.
but by the time i was 13
i knew i could never be a rabbi
why not
because all i understood of the talmud
i never saw god there
you
couldn't lie to yourself that's right
like crazy
i mean people were counting on
but
yours is a respectable profession not to
my family
my parents were destroyed devastated by
my decision
my father sent me a way
to new york
to live with distant cousins
eventually i i
found my place my
life's work
what then
well i immersed myself fully i studied
the minutia i learned everything i could
about the law i mean i felt deeply
inside
their minds but
they were inconsolable
my father never spoke to me again
damn bro
old school jews bro
you're done you had to do it all over
again
did you make the same choices
my choice
the last thing i took away from the
achievers is
we can't run from who we are
our destiny chooses us
god damn
that's what i'm talking about dog
you never really saw that movie about
polka you want to be johnny polka
roberts
you never saw rounders no round is good
the woman in it is quite annoying
the brunette she's another blonde the
blonde yeah they're blind she's awful
every time she's on screen i want to
just like fast forward in the movie
theater she was a cutie for a while yeah
but that's all she had this movie was
just so annoying she was just such a
downer the whole time you know she
wasn't donnie brasco
really she was like an extra but she had
a part that was her first movie they
didn't give her a line they probably cut
the line out of the [ __ ] movie
i got a piss so go you don't play poker
no more huh it's been a while i got to
get back into it if i was here more i'd
play more when you went overseas nothing
no poking places no casinos
no i did some gambling on this weird uh
bingo type game had a market in
east timor
yeah
they're just weird to put money on a
number i figured it out how they how to
play i didn't like solve it or anything
but i figure out and they spin and die i
hit like five to one my first and then i
was playing on house money they're all
staring at the [ __ ] white guy
i just came across like i left in the
morning once and i came across like a
you know just like a once a week
market
and they're all just [ __ ] playing
that for extra cash
hell yeah i remember that they were all
like [ __ ] white guy won five to one
you were really getting into the poker
for a while oh yeah i would win some
[ __ ] tournaments and life got in the
way yeah yeah yeah life gets in the way
it's like
my little hobby no nobody knew who you
were you just go
get high yeah
i would get high at every single break
in a tournament i mostly played
tournaments
every two hours a 10-minute break and i
would like they're like all right
[ __ ] run to my car just immediately
smoke the maui hour was perfect for that
i freed people's souls if i was on that
maui and just go
just for like eight and a half minutes
hear the alarm and then just run back in
breathing out the whole way
set right back down at my seat and then
just [ __ ] see through people
all in time no i'm good call yeah i know
what you have
ace nine like he's ten like yeah i was
pretty close i gotcha how long would you
play for what's the longest tournament
seven until like three a.m eight nine
ten eleven twenty two no no overnight no
i did overnight i did i i i cashed at a
world series event once and you had to
come back the next day
and then another time too in in
hollywood park in those qualifiers in
some places it was like poker month
it was uh no it was at um
commerce
and i i went the next day and then i was
short stacked i think they changed the
tournament time when i thought i was
overslept so they were [ __ ] chipping
me down without me being there and i ran
in and i sat down and [ __ ] bruce
buffer
michael buffer
is it the next table and he's like hey
all right how you doing i'm [ __ ]
playing in a hand and i lost
concentration and i just [ __ ]
made a dumb move and dumped off the rest
of my he came over with the [ __ ] i'm
in the middle of a [ __ ] at the final
just let me alone man final table not
now
have you ever gone to playback
no i've never went over there yeah i
think they played for like actual money
yeah they played that was like
i got like 200 bucks to play for a
tournament if i win bring your drinks
they light your cigars yeah music they
got food i heard i just i'm not a poker
i'm not a card player i like sitting
there and then just most of the hands
just fold so you just sit there and like
think
about stuff
the [ __ ] do you think about you're
playing cards yeah but then you're just
out of a hand for like four and a half
five minutes
you can eat right then or you can just
like think about [ __ ]
wasn't it headphones i'm so relaxing i
always started [ __ ] so relaxing and
nerve-wracking
yeah but dude i played with jerry buss i
played tournaments with jerry buss with
people who had way more money than me
but you all buy in for the same amount
and you're when you're out you're out so
it's an equalizer 225
plus dump 50 goddamn add-ons for no
reason
and then it's like we're all equal you
bust you're out
so it doesn't matter how much money you
got at home or you own the lakers i i
had nothing we're both going to try to
go far in here
yeah it was great such an equalizer now
when you those were fun you played poker
that was it no blackjack no no [ __ ]
baccarat no why the odds are against you
you don't get a [ __ ] drunk mexican on
payday coming in to change the odds
significantly in your favor
you don't get that like you do with the
[ __ ] hundred dollar
no limit tables
oh those are good you get one of those
on payday dumb like how come you guys
are even the limit
how come you guys are all winning and
we're not you guys talking to each other
no man i just sat down with this guy i
have no idea what you're talking about
well then why is all the money over
there why are you playing [ __ ] jack 7
so much what the [ __ ] is wrong with you
bro
you're bad
they're just drunk they feel on top of
the world oh ship it ship it
every time you lost a hand it'd be an
investment in your future because they
[ __ ] oh see i know i can beat this
guy that's right you can
oh you catch those magical paydays on
friday night nights
we'd go down after the comedy store go
at 2 at two a.m right after the comedy
show go 2am come back at like you know
especially if it's on a weekend you have
to worry about traffic we get to the
point where it's like caprillo would be
like we gotta leave now if we're gonna
leave to be traffic or we're here for
another five or six hours because we're
not gonna drive back at eight
so which either leave it six or leave it
ten
and it's like let's keep going i'm open
let's keep going and we just go until
ten who gave a [ __ ]
me cap bring the zc we'd all go down
it was great and then eventually it was
just me
they all stopped
lawrence would go a lot we'd play
tournaments a lot
give signals to each other on the
[ __ ] table
we'd have each other's foots trying to
tell each other if we had ace king aces
or kings
and we always just go to vegas yeah once
everyone's the world series yeah he
cashed in a tournament too how much do
you make i don't know you make it like
if you just cash it's so big it's really
like it's a 1500 tournament you'll
probably make like 2 200
you know just the cash but then if you
wait another hour now because with 3 500
and a whole group of people go out there
it pays off like place like 250 through
like you know 185 pays the same so it's
just like it starts going and you start
raising up and there if you're smart if
you just slow down slow down
you know you don't have to make big
moves play real hands you have that's
what i say and then you just go up go up
go up and money until now you're down to
like three tapers like all right now
it's [ __ ] per place
you know
now i can try to like make some moves
and get ahead
but just outlasts a bunch of the [ __ ]
suckers who get nervous on day two who
talk to [ __ ] buffer and [ __ ] get
distracted wait for those [ __ ]
suckers to go out god i should have done
better than that
there on time still haunts you still
haunts me
you're gonna make a comeback the poker
yeah [ __ ] yeah i just got excited about
it see
yeah man those those are so fun it would
go sunday and it was like if i got out
of there i'd they played seven o'clock
tournaments or was it four o'clock
tournaments at hustler hustle are the
best long tournaments because you really
had to like bide your time it wasn't
like a quick go go all in shove fest but
if i was out by 11 head to the comedy
store go up on potluck if i wasn't out
by 11
i'm just there i'm in the money you know
i mean i'm fine
i'll take sunday off
yeah those would end up like two one or
two
oh god those were fun
so if you know poker and those that
played up just just off i had a credit
card i would take money off the credit
card put it back on i would keep money
at hustle casino so i'm like i need 200
out of my table when you have one big is
like i might be taking this with me you
guys keep it i'll sign out
that's great what was your question so
but if you know poker yeah so the those
drunk guys barely did i was only better
than bad people yeah but they're not
gonna ruin your knife by like hitting on
the next oh no they will and it'll ruin
your night because you're like [ __ ] [ __ ]
they got me sometimes they'll get you
they'll just go all in on anything just
for the [ __ ] fun of it so you just
wait pick up like real hands oh
and then they win they beat you in the
hand we were down to like you don't
really go below five people but you go
up to nine below five nobody is a
jackpot so for some reason nobody wants
to play
but like
it was one guy sitting on one side and
then it ended up being four people over
here like up like here with one guy
alone and that guy was just a drunk dude
in a suit he just kept like
call somebody like raise three he'd be
like all in with like a hundred on top
and you just wait and if you had a hand
you're like yeah call i need to have
like you know ten six you'd have pocket
jacks or an ace king like i'll do that
and then every once in a while he'd hit
and you're like [ __ ] fine whatever
that money's still coming this way we
would just split up his money
it was like hey nobody's fighting each
other we don't know each other but we're
all taking that guy until he's dry
oh those would tip the scales in your
favor so much when you saw that what do
you got tonight
to instead to go down there yeah go down
and take a ride i'll go down smoke a
little butterwood
eat a little bit more of the stall later
you get on there by 11 o'clock no no oh
yeah but i could play the hundred yeah
hollywood parks closed
they're they're building there but
hustlers open and commerce
commerce is the place and congress got
chinese commerce has bimbap they have
good korean
bimbap at at uh at commerce is
legitimately good lawrenceville tested
that too what's the big bump the same
bop no it's just weird sound with rice
egg
kimchi
and then you just like you eat a little
separate a little bit and hot stuff and
you just then you mix it all
so good the recipes to a tremendous fart
an egg
the [ __ ] that comes out of your ass
seaweed in there there is some seaweed
you might as well go to the garlic
restaurant
that first [ __ ] [ __ ] is coagulated
[Laughter]
what's going on with you what's next dog
uh i go back to new york all right uh i
start my tour finally in 2018. when do
you start youtube i'm gonna do some
storytelling show in denver all right
get five guys
um
and then uh and then i go to the wilbur
and fox woods and do like an east coast
run
you know should be cool to go back on
the road doing that joker's cruise
that'll be cool what is the joker's
cruise what is it when oh the first week
of november
you've been going no i never went i'm
going but you've been going you told me
about it seems like fun everyone just
haven't been on the cruise ship before
no
no
the last ship my people were armed was
the one who was sent back
to go on the cruise ship i went on the
disney cruise boom parts of the
caribbean i've been on that that was the
duck house i don't know disney cruise
wait where's the disney cruise go uh
what goes to like disney's they like an
island in the caribbean oh for real
cruise yeah no it's a real cruise oh how
old were you
12 i guess were you happy i got a piss i
guess yeah it was pretty
it's pretty cool for kids
we went for the uh that sounds awesome
whatever it was called
the millennium
are you spraying that from your own part
yeah but it sticks around no it don't
work this is this is a good [ __ ]
night relax all right nobody smelled
nobody even smelled the original [ __ ]
odor what are you talking about when i
dropped that [ __ ] egg before nobody
even sniffed it nobody knew what was
going on nobody knew what happened
stop exaggerating [ __ ] who's
exaggerating you are you're saying that
it smells like farts in here no you i
didn't think i didn't say nothing you're
the one who sprayed febreze yeah i spray
breeze just don't you know give it a
little [ __ ] air in here sometimes you
gotta
you gotta air out the [ __ ] room don't
forget people
you're looking to get healthy you're
looking for supplements you don't know
what to do do me a favor go to
haunted.com right now
between the alpha brain the shroom tech
sport the shrimptech immune
the mct oil i mean it
it just
they're cutting edge they're innovative
and you know what they're healthy for
you and it's tremendous stuff that hem
force protein whether it's the chocolate
or the acai vanilla they'll put a
[ __ ] hem in your skirt you understand
me they got club bells they got they got
kettlebells they got
what they got now they got the new iron
man or something like the mace
and they have the star wars star wars
[ __ ] kettlebells you could you could
throw them up in the air 55 000 times
listen
go to honey.com right now preston church
i'll tell you what i'm gonna do i'm
gonna give you ten percent off your
order delivered to your house all right
you try that [ __ ] out for brain if
anyone what we say it is
you tell them tell me what it does we
don't even want the product back
we'll send you the money alpha brain
opens up your mind it's a bunch of
nootropics and whatnot which i don't
understand yeah what does it do for joe
rogan's world you know what man it makes
you more focused and it makes you think
a little bit clearer
and you have to
you know take them for 60 days you know
it's it's a great little thing for the
[ __ ] money you start thinking better
yeah you start thinking about it maybe
you're a little cloudy maybe you got hit
in the head a few times you smoke too
much weird maybe you smoke too much weed
there's always a [ __ ] dilemma yeah
beside that that's it aries you know now
all right so
rosh hashanah what's in december
december hanukkah
yeah but now all these holidays shift
back and forth so we have sukis in
between yom kippur and hanukkah you got
sukkas sukkot in uh this year first week
of october which is very early sometimes
it'll go to like thanksgiving reform
people don't do those reforms people
don't well you got to build a house
to commemorate being in the desert and
staying i guess
you build the hut your back porch if you
have like suburbs if you have the yard
you build a hut yeah for sure did you
stay back there tarp around it you
wanted to try to sleep in there one
night if it got too cold rainy just get
out of there there's nothing you can do
but it's just palm leaves over the top
as the roof so you have to be able to
see the stars through it
it's great if it's too warm then you get
bees
actually maybe october 4th is like in
the middle
hilarious yeah
and then you have hanukkah commemorates
reclaiming the temple driving the
[ __ ] romans out of little [ __ ]
jewish army driving the romans out the
middle maccabees guerrilla warfare
guerrilla radio
radio
um now how long is hanukkah eight days
eight days but you can do any there's no
that's not a holiday where there's stuff
you can't you can't there's no day where
you can't turn it on enough lights
hanukkah didn't have any of those it's
just oh there's no [ __ ] there's no
shabbat there's no special like holiday
shabbat for hanukkah
you've still got shabbat when it's
shabbat saturday's still shabbat on
hanako but you can do the lights no not
on shabbat okay but on rosh hashanah
even if russian follows on tuesday
wednesday like those are like shabbats
gotcha so you can't turn off lights
saturday or tuesday or wednesday
depending on when it falls out
yom kippur can never fall out on shabbat
because it's too sad for a good hot a
good weekly fun time now shabbat is in
september
shabbat is at the sabbath and how come
they do shabbat the festival now is it
whatever the [ __ ] well it's a different
thing that's an organization
okay shabbat is this just means sabbath
they have a hit rehab for drugs shabbat
yeah or some [ __ ]
because they did a thing for them and
they showed they gave them paperwork of
what services they provide oh really
jewish yeah they do good stuff yeah they
do great stuff over there they stink but
they're good people do they have some
gekko yeah because especially in the
summer time those they don't wash this
it's too expensive to wash those things
all the time
they're heavy
and so they [ __ ] sweat in them and
they stink that black suit the black
suit you can take it off and all this
hands up by itself
those pants stand up by themselves those
[ __ ] things what about the ones with
like the fur hats how what do those
smell like oh they'll smell like
dumpster garbage mixed with the spares
they smell like put on a baseball hat
for a week and 90 degree weather
and take that hat off and sniff it on
saturdays and they like to have squeaky
clean hair to begin with that's dandruff
ridden hair
it smells like toa cheese
their head smells like toe cheese
i i wonder what you have to do to get
the smell out of it or die buy a new
diet you can bury it shoot yourself yeah
and they bury you with that suit no you
don't get a new one
i guess you got it cleaned
i guess you got it professionally
cleaned
wow what a [ __ ] extra expense
so you ready for football season i know
you're a cowboys wanna know uh they beat
the giants yeah they'd be a huge game
huge game
19 to three dominated them dominated 35
minutes 25 minutes to get time position
dak played well zeke played well
hopefully he's not gonna get suspended
because they're gonna call the person
who interviewed the woman who said
there's nothing happened here
they refuse to call that so they have to
go to court now now the nfl all they do
is say listen if you're gonna get down
on us we're not punching people enough
every time it's public we're just gonna
punish people as hard as we can and then
if the courts want to reverse it then
that's on them but technically we did
our part so let's just [ __ ] punish
people without any sort of proof
who knows that's what i'm reading
so hopefully he's back for the world but
not only is it a win it's a giant's loss
they're our chief competitor them in
philly
you learn something new every day
i i think i have decent hopes for this
season for the first time maybe ever
after that win if zeke doesn't get
banned i got high hopes for the season
they do this to me every year every year
i was in [ __ ] myanmar watching
updates of the green bay playoff game
finding a wi-fi somewhere and just being
there and [ __ ] with the with the
blanket over me so cold in the hills
just refreshing every 30 seconds to look
for like what the next play is
i mean hit them in the dan bailey best
player on the quarterback hit that
[ __ ] field goal i'm like yes tied up
and then right back for a note [ __ ]
they always let me down [ __ ] giant
fan no cowboy cowboy whatever the [ __ ]
yeah but they always let me down
they always let me down what are you
gonna do 20 plus years
yeah exactly what was the last time
cowboys won it's the 90s man
it's the 90s they were 93. that's how
they won a playoff game
no no they won one playoff game now yeah
93 and then that was it with leon let he
did something that was such a ball yeah
but it was going to blow out when so i
was like
you [ __ ] yeah people booked it
something was wrong with that oh it
could have made a record for most points
i've ever scored
boogie people [ __ ] oh yeah the over
under maybe it ruined that's the last
time they won 93 did they win any of the
80s
yeah yeah yeah i think they made one one
that 70s was their year two 70s was just
behind pittsburgh but that's a history
[ __ ] i didn't know that
i i followed them in like the [ __ ]
shitty like 90s where they won one game
those are bad
there's they were terrible and then they
got this guy hershel walker
and they didn't build a team around them
they made an amazing trade to the
minnesota vikings and they pretty much
took half the vikings franchise first
round picks the next few years second
round picks every other year third round
picks every other year
just this massive thing plus all these
players for this guy who was a usfl
number one guy
went for two thousand three yards in the
usfl he was greater sriracha could catch
and could run out of the backfield he
was great
but the cowboys just built a franchise
off that was before free agency so you
had who you had and they drafted all
these great players
and they've got all these great players
they keep anybody they want
and they just built this team leon led
emmett smith they had all these great
players michael irvin and they weren't
going anywhere these are all hall of
famers they were just there or they get
somebody through a trade after that but
they built their franchise on that
herschel walker trade and then they were
good
jerry johnson came in he was great then
when we bumped into hershey walker at
the [ __ ] game
watch he's going to say hello to him oh
yeah at the ufc because i knew him from
the [ __ ] usfl wow
god
what my brother's time to get the [ __ ]
out of here we got [ __ ] to do with
people to see what we're gonna eat we're
gonna go to uh the taco place and get
some carnita tacos do this if you're
gonna be there in the [ __ ] november
listen i gotta show you this one
pastrami
done okay done where is it it's by me
it's not too much it's not katz's it's
right by me
and it's just like so succulent and good
and it's not like a giant sandwich it's
just a [ __ ] normal good sandwich yeah
but it's got a little it's a bit of
crowd on there they make it their way
herionitis we'll go there and then we'll
go to [ __ ] do the storytelling show
on thursday night yeah how's that for
you where are you at this week any dates
you want to plug while you're here this
weekend no i got nothing oh we announced
the all things comedy festival last week
of october and in phoenix
so it's the 25th through about the 30th
or 29th
in phoenix look for tickets right now i
don't know google it
i don't know what the official website
is for google it and get tickets there's
a bunch of [ __ ] podcasts going on out
there
bert's going to be out there i'm going
to be out there
i don't know who else benson benson i
think burr
bird's going to be there yeah a couple
people going to be out there just
podcast festival all things comedy
yeah that's i guess that's the only one
me i'll be at the cherokee casino in the
[ __ ] salamon springs this weekend
siloam springs west siloam springs
this saturday night
nine o'clock and then two words are down
i'll be at the pittsburgh [ __ ]
improv
september 27th 28th and 29th something
like that i don't know go to [ __ ]
improv.com
and get your dates all right people
always a pleasure when ari shafir comes
on
uh you know lee syed still looking
handsome and never
handsome and never handsome than ever
that's what i meant to [ __ ] say all
right
right away people want to correct my
english
anyway let me talk to you about
something here for 35 years ever since
we started this podcast people were
asking us for advice especially football
advice really every [ __ ] week
especially when it comes to the patriots
the cowboys
the
the you know the browns whatever
let me tell you this where you're
betting at is just as important or who
you're betting on
so that's why i always tell people to go
to mybookie.ag
i gave you the advice home underdog by
more than seven would you just stop with
that already my boogies
for years and their rep is rock solid
they do 100 cash bonuses
so off the bat you're making money for
doing nothing the browns this week i
talked i told you they're gonna cover
over seven point underdogs at home what
did they do they lost by three and they
have the fastest payouts seriously just
two business days after you win you
collect it's that easy you know who's
gonna win right lay down some cash and
win big today i would only recommend the
service to you people that's been good
to me or my friends and that's what
they've been that's why i'm urging you
if you're gonna put a [ __ ] bet in
this year go with my
this is the way to go you know why you
win they pay it's that easy you have to
sit there wait till [ __ ] thursday
doomsday now
you win monday night football bam
wednesday you pick up your little
[ __ ] envelope they have in-game live
betting the most rewarding player perks
in the business an all-new mobile site
that makes wagering on the go a breeze
so do me a favor all right like i said
why have a winner if you're gonna bet it
with a lop and then they don't pay your
money and he's got a story he lost
himself
boom
join my bookie
and we'll match your deposit up to 100
percent bonus on your first deposit up
to a thousand dollars you can't beat
that use promo code what if you if you
put in 850 they will give you an extra
850 to play with that's how i'm
understanding is that correctly i said
it's up to that so there might be some
levels depending on it so it's up to 100
up to 100 so use promo code church
church to activate the offer visit
mybookie.ag today use promo code
church today
you play you win you get paid this is
your week people
this is your lucky week look at the odds
go to my
ag right now and let's get this party
started
i don't want no [ __ ] odds all right i
already know who's gonna win i'll see
you [ __ ] next week i'll see you
other [ __ ] over in chilliwan
springs at cherokee indian casino where
is that you know where it is in oklahoma
don't play stupid all right go hiking
afterwards sure i'm gonna hike through
the [ __ ] hills
and stick to the [ __ ] cactus i'm not
going nowhere right yeah leave me the
[ __ ] alone put some music on tell her i
said hi
that's disgusting
that's disgusting
the church of what's happening now is
brought to you by when on it
for all your supplement needs listen i
wouldn't be alive if it wasn't for on it
between the shroom tech
and the hemp protein i live off that
[ __ ] go to audit.com right now and press
in charge boom
get 10 off off your order and don't
forget alpha brain you got 100 money
back guarantee and they don't even want
the product back number two ever since
we started this podcast every week some
[ __ ] body calls me and tortures me
about who's gonna win this weekend is it
the cowboys is it the cowboys came
through cowboys is it the patriots it's
always some story well let me tell you
this
where your betting is is just as
important on who you're betting on so
that's why i always tell people to go
with mybookie.ag
join now today and my bookie will match
your deposit
up to 100 bonus
of your first deposit up to a thousand
dollars
that means you deposit they double it
and there you go use promo code church
c-h-u-r-c-h
to activate the offer here's the lock
visit my book e-a-g today and use promo
code church today you play you win you
get paid if you get a home underdog by
more than seven points seven and a half
or more at home
that's the luck you'll win four out of
five times on that that's what they
totally home underdogs
oh [ __ ]
it's wednesday [ __ ]
the 13th
of september
crank this [ __ ] up dog
oh they were so hot
oh [ __ ] it's joey diaz with the two wise
men
the other one got shot
dude this guy's so cool
[Music]
oh [ __ ]
is all you need
oh [ __ ] here we go cocksucker's so
[ __ ] cool
the church of what's happening now with
two of my favorite people in the world
mr hari shafir
and mr lee syetz i
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
sleep away camp when that song came out
jerking off finding quiet moments when
everyone else is out at archery to
[ __ ] whipping out a jerk off
one of those 75 74 74 she was 11. maybe
what year was it 85 86 yeah 11. okay
yeah and then just [ __ ]
so hot so filthy little [ __ ] at
summer camp coming on people's heads and
[ __ ] it was hot and a lot of kids didn't
know what you were doing at 11. i wasn't
whacking off at that age scratching it
but people were talking about sex and
[ __ ] i didn't know what the [ __ ] you
mean you tried to make believe like you
knew what they were saying you giggle
along don't you know what the [ __ ] what
they were saying you know saying like
you giggle ah
you sucked a [ __ ] and then you had to
go home and find out what [ __ ] was you
should
ask somebody [ __ ] older than you
what's going on lisa you look a little
disturbed you know my cam counselor was
the first time i saw like an actual porn
magazine from him yeah and i took he had
had a whole locker in the cabin with it
and i took literally one page home had
four signs
i took one page home and hid it under
the mattress and my mom found it and i
was like oh what was on the tits did you
get used out of it uh yeah [ __ ] yeah it
was a i remember it was like a it was
like a blonde girl but pretending to be
a farmer oh yeah she had like pig tails
and she had like the the red uh
shirt the red what's it called the the
flannel shirt that was the ties up yeah
but with no it was just her [ __ ] out
though oh well nothing not at first okay
she wasn't a [ __ ] but eventually
against that in the spread yeah
eventually and then later in the spread
she
she uh she showed it to you but yeah
that was it i don't even think it had
sex on it
how many times you jerk up to the same
picture the first year of jerking off
yeah when you came your whole body went
through change oh my god you get hungry
and [ __ ]
i had like a really soft blanket like
before i even knew what porn was for a
little while i would just like bunch up
a blanket and just like
rotate on top of it like yeah like
gyrator yeah exactly
just shift around would you blow a load
in your little pants
yeah yeah nothing would come out but it
was exactly the same there comes were
great it was just a blue it was like a
pile of gum without the pellets it just
goes
it makes those noises like a silencer
what the [ __ ] for people don't know at
home especially women